Got Publicists with your,
Huh?
Yeah.
She wanted.
She didn't want me to do this without at
least.
Definitely don't do that on,
on the air with live.
People are going to get mad at you
tonight on the air and you're hearing it
right now.
It's like,
God dammit.
John John's almost finished.
You had all this time almost finished.
You got to finish that fucking thing.
That's an athlete.
That's someone that works out a lot.
Just like those imperatives,
right?
You got to get that food in there,
which is key.
It is key,
but that's shit.
What are you eating?
What does that kind bar thing?
It's all bullshit.
Oh,
it is.
But is that a good one?
Is that one ones with the five grams of
sugar or one of them?
Carmel.
Fake candy bar type five grams of sugar.
Definitely a little closer to that Jon
Jones.
How you doing brother on the road?
You know,
I understand.
I gotta get you some stuff to bring with
you,
man.
Bring some good ones.
He ever,
uh,
ever fuck with that guy.
A primal kitchen.
His,
his stuff.
He's got some great stuff.
I'll give you some before you leave.
I'll just try it.
Yeah,
you're doing the number one thing that
people get mad at on this podcast when
we just fight companion podcast is
chewing.
People get furious.
There's something about being in
someone's ear.
Like my daughter was in my ear last
night and she was chilling.
She's trying to sit on my lap and she
was chewing in my ear and I'm like,
this should not be bothering me.
Like why is this bothered me?
I was having an internal dialog.
I'm like,
honey,
you're eating in my ear and to her.
She's like,
what do you give a fuck?
So I'm eating in your hair.
I'm your baby asshole.
You give a shit.
How old is your kid that this one?
That was on my lap.
Six August.
I have three.
Oh Great.
I got a 20.
I got an eight and I got to six.
Wow.
Good for you.
How many have you got?
A four,
eight,
nine,
six and three girls.
It's crazy,
right?
I'm going to say so bad.
Jeremy Stevens says it's the fighters
curse.
I've heard that a bad ass is good old
girl.
My Coleman all girls.
I think don fries got all girls.
Yeah,
I want to sun.
So there's a surgery that you can do.
Oh,
I'm where?
I guess they take my semen and they take
out all the girl,
the girl hormones.
Whatever chromosomes injected into the
white gives you like a 97 percent chance
of getting a little boy.
Really?
Uh Huh.
Is that legit if you googled it?
I've heard a lot about it.
I haven't limited,
but if it's a possibility that they were
going in that direction for the next
one.
Yeah.
See,
that's one of those things that I would
google.
I would make sure that it's not some
horseshit created by some dude just to
collect your sperm.
I feel like.
I think I heard Kanye did that to get a
boy the second time.
Oh yeah,
come in.
Income.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I obviously got to look into it
extensively before even trying to go in
that direction,
but that's the plan.
Hopefully it's real when you think in
some way.
Now I'm not really too much of a
spiritual one.
I wouldn't say I'm spiritual,
but I don't believe in.
I don't.
How do I phrase this?
Would you worry that you would anger the
gods?
But trying to fuck with DNA.
That's
so funny.
That's a great question.
So I,
I actually thought that,
you know,
because obviously I'm a religious guy.
I thought that my theory has always been
God is gonna give me a son when I am
mature enough to raise a man,
teacher man,
how to be a man.
So that was always my thing and I felt
like,
um,
I felt like God was waiting for me to
get married before a given me and my
fiance,
this boy that's deep and yeah,
that,
that was my whole theory.
I was just like,
when I'm mature enough and you were
married,
you know,
God feels like we're in this good place.
He's going to give us a boy and then I'm
thinking,
you know,
but if we have another girl that trial
and error,
so expensive,
that's 18 more years of raising some
another girl,
you know.
So because me and my wife already had
three,
um,
I call her my wife and my fiance.
She's pretty much,
my wife have been together forever.
Um,
so I'm like,
I didn't want to risk.
I don't want to read.
You think about it in terms of a
financial risk.
Oh yeah,
I can afford to have a thousand kids.
Like what are you doing?
But that's something that gets ingrained
in your hat.
And people always say,
oh,
the cost of raising kids,
you start thinking about man,
the cost,
the reason it's more at the time.
Yes.
That time that you know,
you to put it in,
like,
you know,
you're raising another little girl and
it's all trial and error.
So I'm thinking let's just put a little
science in there.
And I'm like,
I feel like God gives people the
intelligence to come up with
these ideas and these different,
you know,
surgeries or whatever to be able to.
You got to be saying like,
God gives someone the,
the idea to be able to do this.
So maybe he's okay with you.
Choose a boy or girl.
Well,
they didn't have the foresight when they
were writing the Bible to take out
genetic diversity testing or whatever
the fuck they're doing.
What,
what?
What would they be doing?
Like some sort of DNA,
chromosomal jazz.
I don't know what they're doing.
I don't know what the process is.
Yeah,
well people,
I mean wouldn't you say personally that
like people who are religious,
almost all of them sort of pick and
choose what they decide to agree with
and not agree with you.
You're a religious person,
but you have a tattoo of you have a
religious hatoon which is double ironic
as it says in the Bible not to get
tattoos.
Right.
Not to mess with the temple.
But then you gotta pick and choose what
you were listening to.
That's not the way it's supposed to go
either,
but you know where I'm perfect and he
knows that.
Do you think when you were talking about
like I'm wanting to wait until or that
God would give you this opportunity when
you are more mature,
when you were mature enough to raise a
man?
Do you think about that?
Like man,
why do I have to wait?
Like,
why am I not mature enough right now?
if I can internalize that and if I can
understand that,
like what is the difference between me
in the future when I am mature enough to
have a man and me right now?
Like,
why,
why have I not learned enough lessons?
Why not having
a balance myself out enough?
I feel like I,
I've,
I've learned lessons every year,
you know,
every month,
every day.
I feel like I'm growing as a person,
as a man,
but I only,
I know about some demons that I still
struggle with and,
and I feel as if when I'm over those,
um,
I'll feel outfit ready to be able to
raise them and teach me how to be a
proper bed.
But you don't feel like you're over
overdose yet.
No.
Middle of it,
you're in the struggle.
I'm definitely of still in the struggle
of,
of some things,
you know.
But,
um,
but I've definitely got over a lot of
things that I,
that I used to struggle with it,
which I'm excited about.
But,
you know,
life is,
is a,
it's a work in progress.
Well,
you were telling me before the show that
you,
uh,
you don't do instagram anymore,
you're not doing anything,
you just sort of laying low.
You're not doing any interviews.
So like before you were about to do
this,
you're like,
oh shit,
I haven't done anything like this in a
while.
Yeah,
yeah.
The main reason why I decided to come on
your show was um,
I'm getting ready to do this grappling
match against Dan Henderson on the 11th
and um,
there's gonna be a lot of media
surrounding it and there was a lot of,
you know,
I got to do like a one hour phone or
with a bunch of different media guys.
And then there's a,
a few reporters that's got to be there
physically to,
to do some interviews with me.
And I felt like this is kind of just
like a lot of things kind of untalked
about and you know,
people are just wondering how I'm
feeling and what I'm,
what I've been up to and stuff like
that.
And I didn't want to have to answer the
same exact questions over and over 4,000
people,
so I was just like,
you know what,
Joe Rogan has a lot of respect amongst
the mma community and you know,
his fellow goes obviously beyond the mma
community.
He's a smart guy and I was just like,
you know,
I'd rather let me just talk with you
about kind of everything and get it out
of the way.
Um,
but yeah,
outside of this,
this interview with you,
I have not really done anything publicly
since July when the UFC 200 scans.
So you've been on a crazy ride just not
just through July,
but for the last couple of years you've
been been involved in a lot of crazy
shit,
you know,
what are you,
have you been,
are you disappointed in yourself with a
lot of this stuff that I am.
I totally am.
Yeah.
What does it feel like?
Like,
like,
like Gimme the thought.
Like we can go through all of them,
but give me the thought like probably
the most.
I was disappointed in you and I love you
as a person.
I think you're a great guy to jail
things.
I really do.
I've always had a good time hanging out
with you,
but I was very disappointed with you
with that car accident.
When you ran away from that car
accident.
That to me was like God Damn Johnson.
Yeah,
place.
it was.
It was.
I was at a bad place.
It was a.
It was a messed up situation,
man.
I literally was an important mental
life.
Then when I was winning all these
fights,
I was the boy in the UFC.
I'm sponsored by Nike and Gatorade and
you know,
the greatest of all time finishing
legends after legend after legend.
I'm just really in this position where I
felt so untouchable and I just felt like
I felt like everything was meant to go
my way and in that time of my life
started to.
I was obviously,
I was smoking pot,
you know,
majority of my career of drake
drink and you know,
every weekend pretty much,
you know,
to the point of blacking out.
Just lacking out.
Yeah.
Just just being a hammer,
you know,
and just being a total party boy,
but still,
I'm still training my butt off,
you know,
I'm working really hard believer in
really hired,
have big goals,
big dreams,
but just being a party boy and I think I
just took everything that I have for
granted because everything for the
majority of my career has gone my way.
And um,
that,
that morning I got in a car accident,
man,
I just,
it was,
it was just,
it was a huge reality check and it was,
you know,
I think in some people's mind they
envisioned me,
you know,
hitting this car and running up and
seeing that it was a pregnant lady and
then it off Vernon.
And then people said that I came back
and grabbed a load of money,
which is the stupidest thing ever.
Why?
With a millionaire and need to grab
cash,
right?
Unless you run back to the car.
So I literally,
I went through a light,
um,
it was like a green light that said that
I could turn left,
but you're supposed to yield for the
right of way,
right to turn left.
And um,
um,
person came through and I,
I just assumed it was my green light to
go,
obviously being I'm not completely clear
headed.
And I ended up running into a car.
Um,
I was definitely disoriented.
I'm disoriented from the accident,
from the accident for sure.
Just kinda like what the hell just
happened.
It was a really big hit,
but that was fine.
I had no injuries and I just felt like,
well maybe it wasn't that bad of a hit.
So I literally,
um,
step out of the car and I realized like
seconds later I realized my bulls in the
car.
So you bowl my ball,
my.
Yeah,
my,
yeah,
my pop pop pot.
Yeah.
And I wasn't smoking weed in the car or
anything,
but it was in the car,
but my bowl that had residue was in the
car.
So I literally,
I open my car door,
I'd like to take two steps away from the
car and then I go back to the car and I
searched the car because I had it in my
cup holder and when I hit the ball fell
somewhere.
Who knows where it flute you.
But I knew,
I knew shit.
Like I can't find that bull that's gonna
get me in trouble and just having a bowl
of my car.
So I looked for like two seconds and
find the ball and I just took off
running.
Um,
did you look at the other person in the
other car?
No,
I had no clue that it was a woman.
I had no clue that it was a pregnant
woman.
How much time are we talking about?
Like from the time literally from the
time that I hit,
I had,
I was over a fence probably eight
seconds later.
It was,
it was literally a super reactionary,
like just,
I just felt I hadn't been home yet.
I say that a friend's house.
I wasn't drinking and driving.
I,
you know,
my decision was to sleep at my friend's
house because I knew I couldn't drive
home.
He woke up early the next morning to go
to work and he's like,
John,
feel free to stay here and uh,
you know,
you can make yourself breakfast or
whatever,
whatever.
And the guy has a family,
he has a wife and he has a newborn baby
and I didn't want to stay at his house
while he's at work.
So I was just like,
no,
I think I'm okay.
But really I had maybe like two hours of
sleep and um,
I didn't realize that I was still wasn't
ready to drive.
So,
um,
you know,
I wake up and get in my car and uh,
I just wasn't ready to drive or whatnot.
But um,
why didn't you look at the other car
because it all happened so fast.
Yeah,
sorry.
Yeah.
So it all happens so fast and um,
I just knew I was a,
I knew I smelled like alcohol and um,
I just felt like if the police came out
it would be a bad situation for me.
And um,
I just thought the person that I hit had
to have been okay because I was totally
okay.
I was like,
maybe this collision wasn't that hard.
Um,
so I just feel like in a lot of people's
minds they see me as like a,
I knew it was this woman,
I saw this woman hanging out the window
crying and bleeding and sort of
something like that.
And like I just chose the lever and I
didn't know what I had it.
No,
if I had a truck,
I didn't know if I hit a uh,
a punch bug,
I didn't know what it was that I had.
I just knew it was another vehicle you
didn't even look.
No,
I didn't look.
Wow.
And I didn't go back for cash,
but it doesn't make a,
it doesn't make a what I did.
Okay.
The fact that,
you know,
I didn't go back for cash and I really
went back for my boy,
that's,
that's no better.
Right.
Um,
full situation was just a shitty
situation I was in.
I was in a really bad point in my life.
Taking everything for granted.
If you wanted to have a situation come
up with just like worst case scenario,
that is the worst case scenario.
Pregnant woman.
Oh yeah.
It makes me like a monster.
It makes me look a monster.
When you found out I was pregnant woman,
what was,
what was going through your mind?
I thought,
man,
I am.
I'm done.
First I was afraid that there will be
some type of,
uh,
problems with their baby because,
you know,
obviously if she had a difficult
pregnancy then that's,
that's a whole different level of being
in trouble and God forbid if she was
having a miscarriage,
um,
you know,
I would imagine that that would be
$1,000 to put on me.
So I thought about the fact that I went
from just partying and join this career
and this amazing fairytale life I went
from.
I thought I was going from that to like
literally being in jail,
being labeled as a murderer.
So that was my,
that was my number one
thing,
was just hoping that the baby was okay.
What about,
what were you thinking about yourself?
Like when you did that,
when you read,
I mean,
there's no way you can be happy with
yourself that you did that.
What were you thinking?
Well,
I,
uh,
me and my mom have a great relationship.
I'm a mama's boy.
Um,
um,
and then I'm the father of four
daughters.
So,
um,
you know,
if anything,
my,
my respect for,
for women is I have tremendous respect
for a woman and I tried to like,
uh,
obviously being a father,
I like,
I try to,
I just felt like a monster.
I feel like a monster,
you know what I mean?
Um,
I just felt terrible.
I felt I felt really bad.
I was just,
I was mainly concerned with this woman's
health and safety and I'm really glad
that she ended up being okay.
I felt really bad.
I was just like,
do even in the public's eyes,
like you just heard a pregnant woman
like doesn't really get worse than that
but,
but yeah,
I had no clue.
I had no clue that was even a woman that
I hit and I felt terrible.
And what was the,
what was not just the,
what was the reaction from your family
and friends?
Um,
you know,
surprisingly it was,
it was okay.
You know,
um,
they,
they support me so much and they love me
so much and they know that,
you know,
that I haven't really,
uh,
I believe I have a good heart.
They know that I have a good heart.
Um,
and they were just were just thinking
man,
like did anybody step in and say,
hey man,
you gotta get your shit together.
Oh,
I've had,
I've had a lot of people telling me I
need to get my shit together.
And what was it about?
Like what besides that,
what do you mean?
Like besides this one instance,
what other things would people come to
you and say,
Hey John,
you gotta get your shit together.
Well,
kind of all of it,
all,
everything that's happened over the last
two years.
What makes people feel like they can
tell me that I need to get my shit
together?
And I recently,
I recently went outside to my growers.
My garbage man was coming up and I was
late getting one of the garbage out to
the side of the road,
so he waited for me and I've even told
me he was like,
he was dumping garbage and he's like,
hey man,
like I'm waiting to see you fight again.
It's like you really need to get it
together.
Man.
Just parked outside of my little kitchen
pretty much just telling me to get my
shit together.
I've taken like,
everybody feels like they have the right
to tell me to get my shit together.
I'm at the end of the day,
you know,
I sit there and I humbly take it because
the right.
Uh,
yeah,
they're right.
But at the same time,
you know,
how many motherfuckers in the world,
you know what I mean,
like so many people
are into all types of crazy shit and
don't compare yourself to the losers and
the losers.
I know what you're talking to me,
you know what I mean?
Can say hey,
well compared to dudes like to go out
and who knows,
who knows?
I'm fine.
Exactly.
Knows what we're shit this guy's.
And he's telling me to get my shit
together.
It's like just because mostly it's
publicly don't mean you're any better
than I am.
That's true.
But you know that that conflict is never
ending and you can't get involved in it.
That that conflict that you're starting
up in your own brain right now.
It's a rationalization conflict.
You start rationalizing your behavior
versus well,
a lot of other people do worse where a
lot of that is a dead end,
a bad road that a lot of people go down
to make themselves feel better.
The only thing that can make you feel
better is to be pure or your shit
together.
Like if someone comes up to me and says,
Hey man,
you've been ripping off old ladies and
stealing money from the church,
I'd be like,
fuck you.
Talking to him about it doesn't make any
sense.
That's not true at all.
So if someone says something to you,
that's rude,
that's not true.
It doesn't have any impact on you.
But when someone says something to you,
that's rude but true,
then you have to rationalize and then
you have to go,
well,
what about you man?
What's going on in your life?
Maybe you're into some dark shit.
You know,
that's a,
that's a bad road.
And it's a,
it's a defensive road.
And as a fighter it's a natural
instinct.
Somebody hits you,
you hit him back so many attacks you,
you won't.
Yeah.
But what about your weaknesses?
And you want to try to search them out.
And I'm sure a lot of people go through
that when they read social media and
they see these anonymous eggs on twitter
saying mean shit to you.
You Start Thinking,
oh,
I want to know who this fucking guy is
and what's going on in his fucking.
I'm like,
that is a trap.
That's a trap.
Well,
you know,
like I said,
I do respectfully take it like I've
never had someone say,
hey,
you know,
get it together,
John.
And then I sit there and be like,
oh,
well,
you know,
I always,
thank you so much for caring.
Thank you so much for your route for me
still and I and I really appreciate it
and I'm working at it and,
and I,
I seriously have been working on my
personal life tremendously and as of
right now I feel,
I feel amazing.
I feel better now today than I did when
I was a beating everybody's ass and you
know,
sponsored by the world and like I
literally feel better today because I,
I feel like I've conquered a lot of
demons in my personal life.
May feel better,
meaning you feel more at peace
more at peace,
you know,
like not worried about social media all
the time like that,
that has brought a lot of peace to me.
Not worried about what people are
saying,
not even worrying about what's going on
in the UFC.
Like who has the builder or,
or,
you know,
just just,
just being Jonathan Jones and having my,
my group of friends,
um,
across the country who gender like a
genuinely loved me focusing on my kids
every day.
You know,
taking my girls to cheerleading,
practice,
picking them up from school,
dropping off at school.
Basic stuff like me and me and my
fiance,
um,
you know,
living light,
feel on top of stuff.
Yeah.
Being the top of stuff,
you know,
I'll go men no debts,
everything's caught up.
Everything's,
everything's spot on,
you know,
things I wanted to get fixed around the
house,
you know,
that paint chip is paint it now.
Everything's just,
everything's going to.
Everything is so put together right now.
My life,
um,
outside of sports is.
And uh,
obviously haven't had the clear mind.
Something that I haven't had in a long
time,
you know,
I just feel I just feel really good
right now.
So um,
as far as.
And then,
and then also being in a position where
I don't even really need to fight
against it either.
Yeah.
Financially
like don't you though?
Don't you though in your mind?
Oh yeah.
I have to fight because I have to fight
because of the story.
Can't end like this.
Yeah.
Well it's like the financial thing is
beautiful and everything like that.
It's wonderful that you're set for life
and you can just kick back and your
children will be taken care of.
And your wife would be taken care of.
That's all beautiful.
But you have a responsibility of
greatness.
There's very few people that ever get to
the position that you,
not just,
we're in when you won the title,
when you were the youngest ever ufc
heavyweight or light heavyweight
champion.
Not just that,
the youngest ever UFC champion.
Now,
not just that.
There's also a responsibility that comes
with potential.
It's not,
it's not just with what you've done and
you know,
it's what you could have done.
Right?
You,
you fought Alexander Gustafson,
be honest about that.
How much did you train for that
fight?
I trained,
I trained for the fight,
but,
but I,
um,
I definitely,
I had this thing where I just felt
invincible and uh,
did a lot of wild stuff leading up to
the fight.
I definitely didn't give it my all
as far as partying and sleeping right.
Bailey party and stay up all night.
Yeah.
I mean,
when you win a fight like that where you
weren't 100 percent,
does that sort of almost reinforced this
idea that you could do anything you
want?
And then,
man,
imagine if I trained next time,
if it's someone big,
I'll train.
Yeah.
So I have this,
I'm going to share something with,
I'm not sure if I've ever shared this
with anyone else before,
but I had this crazy thing that I would
do,
um,
where I would party one week before
every fight and I did it throughout my
whole career and uh,
and it was stupid,
but it was this mental crutch that I
had.
I literally would one week before every
flight I would go out and I will get
blacked out wasted.
And my logic was if this guy were to
beat me somehow I'm at,
I can look myself in the mirror and say
that,
well,
I lost because I got hammered the week
before the fight.
So it was a built in safety net.
It was a safety net.
Yeah,
exactly.
So I did it my whole career.
I,
I would go out and get hammered when we,
before every fight.
Have you ever worked with a sports
psychologist?
No,
but now,
but now I don't have my,
my,
um,
my old st proof.
I was the first fight that I did not do
that.
Worse performance.
So what was your worst performance?
I think you were very unjustly
criticized that fight because I think
over in St.
[inaudible] is a very tough guy.
He's a very difficult five,
is very strong.
He's got a brutal left kick.
He's athletic.
He moves well.
I believe it was a good performance,
but it was still worst before.
Let's see.
I think over st proves a really tough
guy and he was a tough fight.
And you hadn't fought in a long time.
You were off for how long?
How many months?
Sixteen months or something?
Yeah,
it was,
it was over a year.
Yeah,
it was a long time.
Over a year ago.
Yeah.
And then you're fighting a guy who had
been pretty active and fought some good
guys,
had a great victory,
was shogun and looked real good.
And a lot of his fights and was an up
and comer.
Main thing about events that really
bothered me was,
um,
he was,
he was the most,
um,
while he was seizing.
Hey actually has been fighting longer
than I have.
A lot of people don't realize that,
but he was just so
green and raw still like skill wise,
skill wise.
Like I,
I don't.
Um,
I studied everybody extensively and then
I come up with their patterns.
Um,
I figured out the way they flinch.
I figured out their first favorite
punch,
their second favorite punch,
that third,
their favorite combinations that set up.
So they take downs when they clinched
what side of the head is going to be a
literally everything I know everything
about every opponent,
what side they're going to shoot,
whether it's going to be a head inside
his head outside.
What am I going to do about that?
You know,
I figured out everything.
Why they shoot,
where,
what area of the cage they like to shoot
everything.
Um,
and uh,
with in St [inaudible] he,
he,
he doesn't know what he's gonna do.
He's so that are unorthodox,
you know,
and he gets these random knockouts from
weird angles and he's just wing stuff
and he almost closes his eyes and next
thing you know,
he's knocked somebody out.
You know,
so the scary thing about him was a,
he's so unpredictable and so,
and I had a lot on the line.
Um,
so I just said,
you know what,
this guy is a,
he's in a shell pretty much the whole
fight.
He was defensive,
the whole fight and uh,
and I just thought I had coached through
the fight,
um,
and not really risk anything which I
felt like I let myself down because I'm
normally,
I would just,
I mean normally when you get someone
like that you just,
you know,
take them out,
you should,
I should have just been able to take
them out.
But I was content with winning and I
think that was,
I think that was one of the first fights
where I actually just wanted to get the
win,
get my money,
go back to what I,
my actual goal,
which was Thisi,
um,
instead of wanting to finish this guy
like normal.
So I had to really question my,
I really questioned myself and why I'm
like,
I was like that while I was content with
coasting.
Well,
that was a fight where you,
that had the most pressure on you and
then in a fight you've had before as far
as like people wanting to see how you
respond to the adversity outside of the
octagon.
Right,
right.
I agree.
I had a lot of pressure and I feel like
I responded great to my adversity.
You know,
I did all the things I had to do to get
back,
to
get back to the stage,
you know,
I handled all my probation obligations
and,
and um,
and I,
I stayed healthy,
started powerlifting and hired a
nutritionist.
I looked better than ever.
I felt better than ever physically.
Um,
I did everything I had to do Amanda up
and was responsible for my actions.
Yeah.
Was it Greg Jackson that thought that
the power lifting might have a bit of an
effect on your performance?
You thought that you were doing too much
of that?
Yeah,
well,
I was doing too much of it.
So,
um,
I literally,
I started power lifting and I took off
seven months of martial arts training.
I didn't show up to Jackson's for seven
months and I,
I showed up to this place called Zia
strength systems,
um,
powerlifting gym.
I'm four days a week just getting
jacked,
getting jacked,
African American.
I became obsessed with lifting heavy
weight and I literally didn't know
martial arts training.
And then about four months out from the
fight I started to come into the room a
little bit more.
And then only three months before the
fight,
did I actually start a training camp?
No.
Why?
Why did you do that?
As far as like cardio and things like
that,
wouldn't you think that your cardio
would dramatically suffer from just
lifting weights?
I did a lot.
I had a lot of weight to it
because I had gotten big and I,
uh,
I actually did a lot of,
um,
a lot of cardio training,
but I was also,
I had these new coaches,
new strength and conditioning coaches
who specialize in powerlifting.
So I had to almost,
we had to come up with a plan together
of how we're going to start not weight
lifting and doing all cardio.
And even at the beginning stages it was
like,
okay,
well let's just look lighter,
weights more.
And I'm saying,
no,
I need like cardio,
cardio.
And so it was just like a big learning
thing that we had to do that.
Yeah.
So these guys,
were they,
were they involved in martial arts at
all these,
uh,
my power lifting coach,
I know they were so,
but,
and they were giving you advice about
martial arts training,
sort of learning on the job?
Yeah,
kind of literally the job,
but they weren't giving me advice about
martial arts training,
they,
um,
it was just a learning curve.
I don't think they had ever worked with
an endurance athlete the way that I am.
And so I'm mostly,
they work with football players or power
lift.
They work with a Philadelphia Eagle and
a lot of power lifters.
Yeah.
Um,
but these guys,
to their credit,
they were really humble and they,
they listened and they were able to
quickly adjusted what we were doing
every day to make it more about,
um,
endurance and not about maintaining
muscle and strength and things like
that.
And I felt like I got in really good
shape with these guys,
so,
and now we're at a place because I'm
still working with these same guys and
now we're at a place where,
um,
we realized the importance of endurance,
that we're going to start way farther
out and,
and,
and like I said,
these guys are humble enough to do what
I need them to do is put me through some
strenuous workouts that I think are a
great ideal racial differences in the
right place.
So other than the fact that you did so
much strength and conditioning or so
much power lifting,
what else?
Like what did you feel when you got into
the octagon when you fought over in St
Jude,
did you feel stronger?
Did you feel like your endurance had
been diminished slightly because of all
this power lifting?
Well,
I'm like,
so,
so like I was saying,
I,
uh,
I took off seven months of martial arts
and then I did a three month campaign.
And so if you like anything,
if you take off seven months,
if anything,
your game is going to change a little
bit.
So literally throughout my training camp
I found myself trying to get learning
how to fight again,
pretty much I felt like timing,
timing was off I creativity was off the
things that,
that go to moves that I used to do
weren't quite there.
Um,
I would watch some of my old training
practices or my old fights and I'm like,
man,
I'm not doing this stuff that I was
doing before.
Um,
so I was really nervous going into.
I knew that I was ready to beat dc
because I was so well rehearsed and like
the drills and everything were so Robert
hearst to be DC.
But as far as going into the fight will
open St Pruett.
I just felt that my creativity was Kinda
gone in my ability to improvise or
wasn't quite there.
And that was just from taking off so
much time,
uh,
from martial arts.
So in the fight with ogen St Prue,
um,
I felt really strong.
I felt really,
really strong,
like picking him up against the cage
and,
and taking them down felt effortless.
Um,
as opposed to the way you used to feel,
you felt stronger.
I felt I felt really strong.
Yeah,
stronger.
Um,
what else?
endurance felt good.
It felt good.
It wasn't as sharp as normal,
like a few times when when I took him
down,
I remember I wound up in a punch and I
do a big punch and then I wound up and
then I hit,
hit him again in DC.
Said it was in the back of the head
which wasn't.
It was on the neck,
but
I was throwing big shots.
I know Vince instead of throwing a whole
bunch of shots and that was because I
was feeling lactic acid in my arms.
So I'm.
So that kind of made me nervous that I
didn't have the normal level of
endurance that are normally have.
Do you think that's because you had more
muscle bulk?
I think it was,
yeah,
I think it is because they have more,
most of bulk but on the bright side and
not that this is a good thing to,
to injure someone,
but I didn't break or fracture his arm
with a kick and that's something that
I've never done before.
So that showed me.
That definitely came.
That has to be connected to just develop
and so much power in my hips,
into my legs.
It's a point of like a balancing tipping
point,
right?
Where it's like strength versus
endurance and trying to find that
perfect.
Right.
And right now,
as,
as I sit here today,
um,
I'm,
uh,
I'm using my past experience and you
know,
to measure what I'm doing as we speak.
So right now I'm strong as hell.
Um,
but my insurance is actually in a really
good place right now and I'm not
fighting until July.
So now we're figuring it out right now
as we speak.
When you got really big,
were you doing that?
Were you thinking,
Hey,
you know,
one day I'm going to fight heavyweight.
Let's see what I would be like as a
heavy.
Wait.
No,
no,
I didn't.
No,
I didn't know what I was going to do at
that point.
Um,
I just,
I just needed something to be passionate
about.
Um,
something that's to be competitive about
while you were suspended.
Suspended.
Yeah.
And uh,
you know,
I,
I went through a real self destructive
state right after the car accident and
then how,
so I just started to party more.
I was,
I was really,
I was really depressed.
Yeah.
The belt had been stripped from me and
I'm not until Anthony Johnson and Dcf,
uh,
um,
that first time that I did,
I joined the gym and get my,
get my self together.
Why was that?
Just watching that fight competing for
your belt?
Yeah,
just seeing them compete for the bill.
That's myself,
man.
I am wasting and wasting talent.
I'm wasting everything.
Like,
you know,
I believe I can be both of these guys
and they're up there and uh,
on tv where I should be and I'm sitting
here at home,
I'm kind of,
you know,
living in this depression.
And so I'm literally,
the next day I called,
uh,
the,
I walked down there stoned,
right?
And,
and,
uh,
just like,
Hey,
I need to get my life together.
I need something.
I need something to
be excited about,
something to,
to inspire and motivate me,
get me up,
get me out of the house.
And,
uh,
and I just completely turned everything
around from that day for it and just
started to,
to,
uh,
find a new passion and,
and that was weight lifting and I,
I got so strong so fast,
um,
and it became,
it became everything to me just for my
numbers to go up every week,
um,
and which they did.
And I found myself really happy again,
like,
you know,
squatting 500 pounds would be in 64 and
the only way in,
you know,
to 25,
with these really skinny legs,
500 pounds is a lot of weight,
like dead lifts and 600 pounds.
You know,
there were guys who had been training at
that gym for years who still can't do
those types of numbers.
Um,
and I was able to do it.
So I was just like,
man,
you know,
I can do anything I put my mind to.
And uh,
I just thought I was going to become one
of the strongest motherfuckers in
Albuquerque.
That was my,
that was my plan.
Well,
power lifting gyms are very competitive
and guys get super hung up on the idea
of like lifting heavier and heavier
weights.
Hooked.
I had a Mark Bell on the podcast before
and we also did a podcast in Columbus
with a Louie Simmons who's a world
famous power lifting a guru and he's a
fucking maniac and it's all with all
those guys.
It's all just about putting up big
numbers.
Keep it going,
keep it going,
keep it going.
Heavier numbers,
you know?
Yeah,
it was,
yeah.
I fell in love with it.
It's crazy sort of discipline.
It is.
Yeah.
So it's so simple to use,
just lifted up,
but it's very satisfying for people
looking at it like,
who gives a fuck if you squat 500
pounds,
but when you're doing like screaming.
Exactly.
Everybody,
high fives,
chalks flying in the air.
It's the best.
I'll tell you.
I love it.
I,
I really love power lifting and all
about getting injured though because
that's a big part of power lifting until
I have a pretty good traders and,
and um,
and they teach me the right way to do
things,
but they also allow me to,
um,
be out of position a lot of times too
because,
um,
a lot of times people focus on the
perfect form at everything,
but when you looked at real big wait,
you're not always going to be in the
perfect form.
So they,
they almost allow me to be out of
position.
Sometimes you are not in the form is
still power through positions.
That way you're,
you're strong grappling sense.
Yeah.
You're strong in Everett,
you're showing every,
every,
every part of the movement,
whether you're a former bad form,
you're still able to lift big weight.
Well,
that's the big theory behind functional
strength,
right?
That's why people like doing things like
that
power cleans and presses because it's
such an awkward thing to do with the
weight and you're,
you're in weird movements and you're
doing things with your whole body right
now.
What are you doing
days?
So these days I am a,
I have just been doing,
um,
uh,
are you back on Jackson's a bunch of
power lifts and a bunch of wrestling and
Jujitsu?
That's been my thing lately.
No striking.
Uh,
no.
I haven't done any striking.
My whole goal is to not get punched in
the head at all.
That's your goal.
Well,
that's what my plan is.
I'm going to eventually answer my
workout routine to where I'm doing a lot
of myths and working on my versatility.
I'm working on my versatility and,
and just my abilities on my show.
You,
you're not throwing any punches these
days.
Not throwing out kick now,
but it's crazy to me,
but my plan is to get into that.
That's not going to last for too long,
but I won't be doing too much sparring.
Especially heavy spine.
Right.
But even without doing any sparring,
you don't hit the bag you don't know.
Lately I've been doing a whole bunch of
wrestling and Jujitsu.
Wow.
And I'm really starting to love it to
just Jujitsu will.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm really starting to love Jujitsu and
Jujitsu has been the art that I've
neglected the most over my entire career
and surprisingly I have the most
submissions in light heavyweight
history.
Um,
I think can Sha Kim shamrock is right
behind me with maybe five and I have
six.
Ken shamrock are frank,
one of them,
one of the shamrock brothers are behind
me for most submissions in.
Well,
Ken was never a light heavyweight,
right?
I mean Ken went to light heavyweight
when he fought Tito,
but in the early days,
like when he was,
he was a heavyweight.
I'm sure someone could figure,
figured out is a light heavyweight and
the Tito days.
But that was ken,
you know,
later on in his career.
How many submissions did frank have?
Maybe it's frank,
I dunno.
Keto Frank.
I think one of the shamrock brothers are
right behind me and some interesting
legends.
Legends of the sport.
Yeah,
pioneers,
man.
But now I love Jujitsu,
And will you bill for it?
That's for sure.
These long arms,
man.
I'm,
I'm becoming a joke man.
I'm shocked.
I would assume that
someone who is a professional mixed
martial arts fighter has to at least
maintain a maintenance level of
striking.
Alright.
Constantly.
And my plan is to get back and I still
July still very far away
now when it's July.
How does that work when you're
suspended?
Because,
uh,
this is a question that I've always
wanted to know,
like if you're suspended for ped or
something along those lines,
are you not supposed to train with other
fighters that are in the UFC or is that
bullshit?
I,
I haven't heard anything about,
about.
Because that sounds crazy,
right?
That's the train.
Especially if you're trying to help
friends.
Right.
It would be very therapeutic for someone
who's on the outside
and that's.
I spent a lot of time helping other
fighters.
Does that help you a lot when you're
trying to get back into things and to
sort of just someone in my house
studying their opponents?
Yeah,
that's a,
that was one of the best parts about MMA
and martial arts in general I think is
helping friends
given back something.
That's to me too,
because martial arts can be a very
selfish sport,
you know,
it's a,
it's a team sport,
but um,
if you're not putting yourself first,
then you're not going to make it to
certain levels.
I've been really selfish my entire
career and um,
that's one thing my coaches have always
gotten on me about,
Hey John,
I know you live in New York.
I know you got a family,
but you need to get back down here to
help these guys.
They have a fight coming up.
But now that I live in Albuquerque,
I'm constantly giving back and helping
other fighters,
especially since I have all these
suspensions happen.
Do you surround yourself with too many
people that liked to party?
I used to.
You used to.
I used to for sure.
Yeah.
I used to have a lot of wild friends.
And when did you stop hanging out with
these people?
With the car accident?
Um,
or like,
no,
after the car accident when I,
when I decided that it was going to be
completely sober,
I uh,
I let loose a lot of friends and it was
crazy because,
um,
I used to,
my phone used to blow up on Friday
nights because everybody knew that John
was going to be buying everything that
people need to know.
Like I literally,
I'm that guy who went to the bar and um,
I would just buy like 40 shots patrol,
right?
And I'm just like.
And literally if you're standing around
me,
you're getting a shout out patrolling,
just passing them out.
Right?
And next thing you know,
people who don't even know each other,
they're all hugging and I'm really good
at merging people together and have
strangers and having a great time.
And that was my thing,
like walk into a bar where I know five
people and now I have 20 new homies and
like everybody's just hanging out.
Um,
and so when you're like that,
you know,
Friday nights come around,
8:00,
everybody's like,
yeah,
where are you going to be tonight?
You know,
that's,
you know,
if I'm out there's going to be more
people around,
you're going to have a way better time.
Your chances of getting laid is going up
because you're hanging out with me.
It's just the truth.
I just had a bunch of people around me
and um,
since I became sober,
a lot of those phone calls,
they slowly,
they slowly stopped,
you know,
and so now I'm a,
I've been sober for almost 16 months and
um,
and now I'm,
I have had the best times of the best
times.
I,
I remember everything that happens.
Um,
my friends don't try to ever encourage
me to drink or anything and,
and uh,
so they know I'm not going to.
And um,
I just had the best times,
had the best times.
I'm.
And how were you able to make that
transition?
Did you follow many program stop being
no idea and I just stopped and I stopped
answering my phone call for a lot of
people.
Um,
and I,
um,
I just kinda went into hiding for a
while.
I just,
um,
I just stayed away from the scene until
I felt like I was strong enough to just
not do it.
And um,
and,
and it,
it helped,
it helped a lot.
And now do you ever go to bars now and
order a water or anything like that?
Yeah,
do that.
I go out,
I go,
I'm and uh,
I'll drink red bull,
red bull,
whatever.
I'm in a situation where a lot of people
are drinking.
Sometimes I feel like I'm just kind of
chilling and like a little bit too
chilled out.
So like in order to like keep up with a
bunch of drunk people that are talking
to drink red bull,
drink a red bull.
Too many of those though,
man,
it's terrible for you,
but I mean it's way better than just
getting turned up.
So it's funny because I,
I've developed this,
uh,
this way of just having so much fun,
completely sober where a lot of times
when I'm leaving like a place,
someone be like,
hey,
how are you getting home?
I'm like driving.
So it's great.
I really do appreciate my sobriety.
I love it.
I know you were having,
you were saying you were having a
problem with pot.
Yeah,
I did.
I,
I've,
I've been,
uh,
I've been a stoner since high school.
Yeah.
Um,
is that like stopping that,
was that as easy as stopping drinking or
is it a,
was more difficult?
It was,
um,
s
it was,
I think stopping pot was really tough
because I literally didn't associate
with too many people who didn't smoke
that that's the way I kind of like a lot
of people in my own team.
I didn't hang out with them because I
was,
I was kind of one of the hardest working
guys on the team,
but a little bit of a bad boy and none
of my teammates were really a bad board.
Meaning you smoke pot.
I'm just being an.
I was just always down for a good time,
you know what I mean?
So I just kind of,
a lot of my friends were people who
weren't martial arts,
had anything to do with martial arts and
I would always kind of associate with,
um,
just just party people,
people who would like to have fun.
Um,
so I realized once I quit smoking that I
really didn't know too many people who
didn't smoke,
so I had to kind of start
hanging out with people who didn't
smoke,
which I kind of found,
I thought it was
boring.
You
don't like to stare up at space,
they don't want to go to the mountains
and meditate well fucking cross legged
position
people who are just straight,
you know,
we're always just straight and um,
and I had just,
I had to find different activities to,
you know,
because when you're hanging out with
people who don't party,
you know,
they have certain ways that they have
fun and it's usually based around a lot
more activities I feel like.
So I got into mountain bike,
mountain biking and um,
you know,
jogging more fitness,
just laying on fitness and things like
that.
So now,
you know,
fitness is like my drug.
I really love being strong and being
healthy and like I do mountain biking
and Jujitsu.
I do a lot of Jujitsu these days and,
and so that's Kinda like,
that's what I live for outside of
family.
And of course,
well,
it sounds to me that you've done an
audit of your life and you've looked at
all the issues that you're,
you're,
you're dealing with,
and you decided to not engage in them
anymore.
Have you write things down?
Do you write goals down or,
or things that you demand of yourself?
Do you ever do that?
I do.
I have a,
I have a
list on my phone of different ways of
thinking that,
that I want to stand for
different things.
You think you're thankful for,
you know,
different ways of thinking,
different ways of thinking.
Yeah.
That,
uh,
that I want to stay for you.
I do like,
like how so?
Um,
just little things that helped me be
patient and,
and to be loving into
appreciate.
Um,
there's just,
I've had to look through my phone,
that kind of,
I just,
I just write down a lot of reminders of
what I stand for,
you know,
and,
and how I,
how I view things and yeah.
But I do write things down.
Yeah.
Now when you look at the future and you
see yourself from here on out,
do you feel like from now on,
for,
from my time on this earth,
no more drinking,
no more pot,
no more partying.
Um,
I do believe that I'll drink really
advise as um,
just because I
coming out of high school I started
drinking in high school and I always
felt like I needed alcohol to be cool or
to um,
put myself in certain situations to,
to conquer anxiety or whatever.
Um,
to be a part of the crowd and to have
fun and relax.
Yeah.
I always thought I needed alcohol and
um,
so I got to a point where I couldn't
just go out and have a drink.
I would always get to the point where
everyone's getting crazy and things are
getting wild,
you know?
And,
and um,
I never really had the opportunity to
develop a healthy relationship with it.
It just,
it just went from high school to college
when you get even more to being famous
and being able afford to buy everybody
drinks every night.
Right.
So I,
I just,
my relationship with alcohol it,
it became unhealthy and I never went
through a period of time where I,
where I had a healthy,
mature,
responsible relationship with it.
Now being sober for so long,
I know that I can have one drink and
feel a little bit of a buzz and catch an
uber home or whatnot or I know that I
can go out and not have a drink at all
and be the life of the party.
I know that I can go out and not have a
drink at all and approach someone and
talk to someone with zero anxiety or
feeling like,
oh,
I,
you know,
I could sit amongst the group of drunk
people and know that I'm cool in my own
skin just the way that I am.
And that's something I never really had
the opportunity to experience until now.
And so,
um,
now I feel like I'm in a mature enough
place where,
um,
if I wanted to have a drink in the
future to celebrate a victory or
something like that or a glass of wine
at home with my fiance,
I know that I could do that now.
Um,
so I just,
my relationship with it and it's
completely changed and I,
I believe that I could drink in the
future and not run into some of the
wild,
you know,
crashing a Bentley into a pole.
Stuff like that that I was doing before.
When you say you believe you could,
you know,
it's interesting.
I'm kind of talking out of my ass here
because I've never had a problem with
alcohol.
But I know people that have.
And the people that have had a problem
with alcohol,
they,
the way they describe it,
they're like,
I can't do it.
Like if I go back,
I will go all the way that there's a,
there's a thing that alcohol does to you
where it says,
or drugs,
you know,
like just a little bit,
man,
just a little bit.
Come on.
We're just going to get a little bit,
just a little bit,
just a little shot.
Just a little.
Just a little beer.
What's a beer?
Everybody has a beer.
Come on man.
And then that's the siren song.
That leads you back to the rocks.
I feel like,
um,
I had a problem with alcohol but I never
wanted to admit it.
Like when you say you had a problem,
did you have a physical problem?
Like when you got it off the alcohol,
did you have withdrawals?
Did you feel weird?
You know,
I feel weird.
I wasn't waking up and drinking every
day.
So it's a psychological thing.
It's good.
Yeah,
I was,
I was getting hammered on the weekends.
Right,
right.
Um,
it wasn't waking up in and like I didn't
need alcohol,
but I always said to myself,
I don't have a problem with alcohol.
But then when you run into a pregnant
woman,
you have a panel of alcohol.
The day that something affects you,
the first Gwi you know,
it's a problem.
You weren't thinking straight.
Something was caused you to not think
straight and it was your actions and
what you chose to take into your body,
and then you said,
all right,
I'm done with that,
but you feel like you could get back to
that.
I feel.
I feel like I'm.
I feel like alcohol.
I
was never really like.
I was never really addicted to alcohol,
was addicted to 'em.
I just really enjoyed partying a lot and
I made a lot of bad decisions with
alcohol,
so now I,
I really have had the time to see
clearly
where I went run with alcohol.
Obviously again,
being a public figure,
I live in a small town.
I never needed to be getting blacked out
in public again anyways.
It's just something that I look back and
I hear stories.
My boys were like,
Yo,
you remember the time you do this?
I'm like,
oh no.
I used to get blacked out in public.
It looks a little bit in this small town
that I live in.
It's just like.
So I,
I just,
I've had a lot of times they evaluate
marijuana actually is something that I
don't think I want to go back to really
to,
I don't think I want to go back to and I
don't feel like you have an unhealthy
relationship or had an unhealthy
relationship with marijuana.
I,
I re,
I have,
I was smoking way too much pot.
I was poking way too much pie.
Literally breakfast,
lunch and dinner in between workouts to
study film to do everything.
I was just,
I was just in it for me.
There's some functional smokers who can
wake up and they have eight things
they're going to do that day and they do
all eight things like me.
I would wake up and I had eight things I
needed to do that day and I'd be like,
ah,
I got three of them done today.
Like I'm good with that.
Like I just,
I,
it just,
it slowed me down,
slow me down and now that I haven't been
spoken to,
I just feel a lot better.
I feel a lot better.
I feel um,
I feel more on my game.
I feel sharper sparking up a joint right
now.
Go ahead and saying.
I know it's probably hard for you to
hear it.
I know this fairly well.
No,
I mean honestly everybody differently.
Absolutely does.
It absolutely does.
That's important.
Sodas,
red bull and so does alcohol and so does
everything else.
Yeah.
You know,
it was,
it was all day every day for me.
But do you think that you,
um,
was it all day every day because you
were looking for an escape or was it all
day every day because it had formed a
habit and you just,
that's what you were used to doing.
It became a,
it just became a way of life.
It became a way of life for me.
When you're dealing with the amount of
stress and just the amount of pressure
is probably a better word of being,
you know,
one of the great fighters of all time.
I mean,
you're without a doubt one of the best
fighters that's ever fought in mma and
there's so many eyes on you and there's
so much pressure and there's so much
money involved and accolades and all
these different things.
These,
these,
you know,
hey John,
we've got a business meeting for you.
Hey John,
this company wants to talk to you about
doing this and hey John,
and there's just so much coming your
way.
Do you feel like it's almost like you
had set yourself up in a position where
you needed like some escape.
You needed an escape valve and that's
what you had found through the drinking
that's you had found through the pot.
You'd found these ways where you could
not be Jon Jones for awhile.
We could be the blacked out dude at a
bar.
All of a sudden you feel normal.
You know,
normal as normal as you can feel by
being a 20 whatever year old millionaire
fucking throwing shots around and
albuquerque the,
you would found a valve to release you
from some of the intense pressure of
being one of the baddest motherfuckers
on the planet.
Yeah,
yeah.
I,
I agree with you.
Yeah,
absolutely.
It definitely made you feel,
uh,
for those moments,
your hands away from you.
She just blocking the microphone and
I,
um,
yeah,
I,
I do agree that it is for those moments
made me kind of feel
um,
normal like normal.
Yeah,
for sure.
Especially the bar thing,
especially the bar thing,
like going out and just having a good
time.
Like sometimes I,
I forgot that I was a celebrity and that
there was a lot of eyes on me and,
but for those moments I felt like I was
like,
I think I was one of my biggest
problems.
I felt as if I was amongst.
I didn't really hold myself to a higher
standard because of who I was and what I
did.
I,
I've,
and even to this day,
I just feel like I'm one of the guys
like where you are.
Yeah.
In one of the guys like,
I,
I don't try,
I don't really seek hanging out with
other celebrities.
All my friends are like,
I'm just normal average joe guys.
And,
and,
uh,
back when I used to party,
I used to feel like that was me just not
being John Bones Jones and just being
one of the guys,
like just doing the wild shit that
everybody does it.
And then when something bad happens,
it's like you're quickly reminded that
millions of people around the world know
exactly who you are.
So it's just,
it's like,
but isn't it,
it's a two edge sword too because the
people that get completely lost in the
idea that they are this unique and
special person,
you eliminate yourself from all those
other folks and you,
you separate yourself and that's
extremely hard to relate and there's a
lot of celebrities that go into a shell
and everywhere they go they have
security that takes him places and
they'd get delusional.
They have a,
they have a completely distorted
perception of how people interact with
them because they don't just go hang
with people.
Right?
Yeah,
that's,
that's definitely not me.
I,
um,
I meet a lot of people and people say,
man,
you just don't act like you don't have
famous.
I'm just like,
I don't know.
Like I like,
I really have a lot of pride and just
doing what,
like just normal shit,
like going to places that most people,
even fighters in Albuquerque,
you don't don't go just being amongst
the people and,
and I,
I think a big part of me long to just
kind of just be not famous sometimes.
Now my question,
the reason why I asked you that as,
how do you plan on handling that now?
Because if you're not going to be
drinking and you're not going to be
smoking pot and you're,
you're,
you're going to mean right now you're
living life has just Jon Jones,
the person and happy with your family
and happy with your life and just
working out and having a good time doing
Jujitsu and all that stuff,
but eventually everything's going to
ramp back up again.
Media obligations going to ramp back up
again.
All these things are gonna happen and
the pressure is going to be back on you
again.
What are you going to use as an escape
valve then?
Hm.
Have you considered that?
No,
I haven't really.
No.
That's very important.
I feel like,
uh,
I feel like I've matured in a way where,
um,
I don't think it will affect me the way
it used to.
I've really had the opportunity to step
away from it all.
I realized what I had and who I am,
what I was.
And um,
and um,
I just feel above what used to be.
Yeah,
I feel above the way.
I used to like
let so much consuming.
Like even right now,
like,
I don't know,
it says just so hard to explain it.
I just,
I don't feel like I'm in the same.
I don't feel like I look at things the
same.
Well,
I'm sure you don't.
I mean that's the thing about growth and
that's one of the things that when
people are haters,
what they try to do is lock you down to
the old you,
right?
They try to lock you down to you at your
very words.
Yeah,
man.
I remember that Shit in 2010.
You said that fucked up thing when you
were blacked out.
That's you,
Bro.
Remember that I was blacked out.
What did I say?
You tell me,
you know when someone can,
someone can believe that they are their
past,
but we're not know you're.
You have not had fuck ups.
Then you don't understand the
consequences.
Yeah.
I mean you've had considerable amount of
fuck ups and a lot more than the average
person in a public sense.
There's a lot of people that have done a
lot of fucked up things,
but no one knows about it and the
repercussions they feel it's not the
same as yours.
You feel the repercussions of millions
of,
first of all,
millions of people that loved you,
that were disappointed.
Millions of people that were jealous of
you that like I fucking told you was
going to throw it all away.
There's a lot of that to get people
psyched that you fucked up far,
far from
though in our way.
Sometimes I'll get people to write me
and say,
do say things like,
oh,
you ruined a great career.
Or like you a.
like people have this mindset that it's
all over.
Yeah.
I saw a lot of people saying that.
People that I,
I,
I like said that and it's like,
I was like,
you're crazy.
You're an idiot.
You're crazy.
He hasn't thrown it.
I haven't thrown it away right now.
There's a pause going on,
but as far as it being all over or
whatever it is just so far.
True.
Do you,
do you fall boxing a little bit?
A little bit?
You know,
Bernard Hopkins Story?
No.
Bernard Hopkins,
one of the greatest boxer of all time
for sure.
And he'll,
he'll fight December 17th for his last
fight at 51 years old because he's a
goddamn defensive wizard.
He's still does commentary for Hbo,
still sharp as a tack,
but Bernard Hopkins went to jail and uh,
he decided when he went to jail,
when he was young man,
he decided that from that point on he
was going to be disciplined and there
there's no more bullshit and his life,
no more robbery or assault or any of the
shit that got him into the position.
Whereas in and then he was going to
dedicate his life to being a world
champion boxer.
And from that point on,
he became one of the most disciplined
boxers ever.
Never ate bad food,
never drank,
never did anything stupid,
always was in shape.
And we'll go down in history as one of
the all time greats,
guaranteed shoeing hall of Famer.
And I feel like Bernard Hopkins was
created by the darkest moment of him
being and him doing time in jail.
And when he came out of that jail,
one of the first things that I'm.
One of the corrections officers said to
him was,
you'll be back.
And he,
he used that as fuel.
And he knew that like,
there's no fucking way I'm going to look
at that dude again.
There's no way.
There's no way he's right.
And ultimately Bernard Hopkins escaped
his demons by facing them,
by being in hell.
But being in hell,
I think he was in jail for,
I forget how many years,
but just enough,
just enough to cement and his eyes to
hardened him to the fact that what he
needed was discipline and control over
his own destiny.
And I think that for a guy like you,
you can take all those dark moments that
you've experienced over the fuck man.
You think about it,
man,
you got away pretty light.
That girl could have died.
You know,
a horrible things could have happened
while you were drunk driving when you
slammed into that,
that Bentley into the truth.
Although all these terrible things could
have gone wrong that you kind of got
away with.
He kind of mean you.
Boy,
I mean,
if you wanted to think that someone's
looking out for you,
you've got all the evidence in the world
that points to someone actually looking
out for you.
That's great for sure.
Something out there,
whether it's luck or whether it's
intention or whether it's God or
whatever the fuck it is,
man.
What the bottom line is right now at
this moment,
you are still in your athletic prime.
You're still only six months away from a
sport.
When is your suspension?
About eight months,
eight months away from our suspension
being released.
And I mean that's.
This is all a great thing.
How old are you now?
You're 30,
29,
29 be when?
When's your birthday?
July notice.
So you'd be 30 when you come back,
you know,
20 nights though would prime.
That's you.
That's you at your best.
You really,
your prime is like 32.
That's why I like,
um,
I put the,
I put the Jordan,
the Jordan crying face as my twitter
picture.
Have you seen that?
I put that up with you with the belt on
the Jordan phase.
The reason why
that up is because a,
is because,
um,
I know that right now I'm in a position
to do some magnificent and extraordinary
things.
I,
uh,
I know that because I've made so many
mistakes,
I make the perfect role model.
I make the perfect person to,
to,
um,
to still be able to inspire millions of
people.
There's very few people who are,
who are perfect and flawless and just
that clean cut,
never did anything wrong.
Athlete a,
there's way more people who are like me
who has struggled with drugs or just
being an idiot or just doing wild shit
way more people who have lived their
parents don't let their families down.
Let their friends don't let themselves
down.
Um,
and because,
because I've made so many mistakes on
it,
on such a public,
you know,
such a big scale and so public,
um,
I feel like all the great things that
I'll do from here on out,
we're going to be that much greater
because of where it came from to,
to do it.
I feel like I'm,
I feel like my best is yet to come and
there's just,
I feel like I'm in a position to,
to really touch a lot of people and
inspire a lot of people because of where
I came from.
So I'm really excited.
Um,
is that something you concentrate on
more than you constantly mean?
Do you concentrate on that as much as
you concentrate on just doing it for
yourself?
Um,
do you want it for doing it for other
people?
Um,
motivates me probably more than doing it
for myself.
Why?
Why is that?
Is that from all of the accolades that
you've received from all the fans
realize that you have all this love out
there from all these people?
Yeah.
I just feel like I don't need it.
I don't need it anymore.
I feel like I,
um,
I feel like I've done everything
already.
I've been in all the wildest situations
I've had all the craziest experiences,
stayed at the nicest hotels.
I've seen the world of eight at the
nicest rest.
Like there's nothing else that I really
need out of this,
uh,
out of this thing.
I've literally been there and done that
already.
Um,
um,
I feel like I'm,
I just feel like ultimately I've already
gotten so much out of this sport and
what I need to do is to truly get
something.
What I really need is to know that I'm
changing lives.
Like that motivates me more than,
than anything else right now.
I'm the story,
the legacy.
And um,
so the reason why I put that laugh in
meme up is because I'm laughing at my
pain and my struggle is right now I'm
laughing at what I'm going through right
now because I know my future is just so
incredibly bright and I know the impact
that I have.
I know I know what I can do and what I'm
going to do it.
Like right now I'm just,
I'm in a waiting period where I have to
wait before I can show the world what
I'm actually capable of,
what I can be and what I'm going to do
for someone else one day.
Um,
and it's also laughing at like people
who actually think that I'm out down and
out,
like people who actually think that my
story is over or you know,
it was just like,
I'm just laughing at it all because what
I have done is like,
I've seen some athletes come back from
way worse stuff,
rape charges and murder and attempted
murder and,
you know,
all this type of crazy shit.
You don't have anything.
I've done.
I have a party too much and I've done a
lot of stupid stuff like from being a
party boy.
And I know I'm not a bad person.
I'm not like this evil athlete,
you know.
Does it bother you when people think you
are because people.
No,
no,
I didn't.
I don't because you want to ask people,
you know,
there's like,
no,
I don't.
There's people who wants to believe that
I'm this terrible.
Uh,
you know,
one of the worst things that has ever
happened in sports,
you know,
people want to believe that because they
just don't want me to be all that I can
be and
people look at the worst case scenario
and they look at the worst possibility,
you know,
they look at you as this guy has had so
much success,
so many things handed to them that maybe
he thinks he's better than everybody
else now has been handling.
Of course,
of course.
Yeah.
But they don't,
they don't think about it that way.
I know,
I know that,
but they don't think about it that way
when they see the worst case scenario.
I mean,
the way it was played out a pregnant
woman in a car.
And you in your practice when you took
off.
Yeah,
I mean it is like for the haters,
it's like a dream come true.
Yeah,
it is.
Okay.
But I can,
man,
I.
One thing I've learned about myself is
that I can't be held down.
I don't,
I'm not held down very easily unless
you,
I just can't be held down.
Man.
I deal with adversity very well,
man.
I always find a way to get my shit
together and,
and dig myself out of a situations and
like,
and ultimately rise above.
That's beautiful.
As long as you don't count on it,
right?
Oh well now where I'm sick of getting in
my own way and like,
like UFC 200.
Let's talk about that.
I literally what happened.
I did everything that I could to be back
in a position to win that belt bed.
I was getting ready to just show this
triumphant amazing story of someone who
just made it through a hit and run
situation.
It had almost had everything taken from
them and got it all back.
And then,
um,
and then,
I'm sorry,
I'm thinking about so many things at
once.
We're happy with.
So let's just talk about what happened.
You,
you tested positive for some
estrogen inhibitors or blockers
yesterday.
Didn't blockers that a lot of people
associate with people who take steroids.
People take steroids,
they want to restart their system,
or if you want a testosterone boost,
you take clomid or clomiphene and these
are,
these are standard drugs in the steroid
users world.
Yeah.
This is all new for me.
Um,
basically what did you take?
So I took a,
I took an offbrand Cialis bill off
brand.
It was,
it wasn't actually alice,
but it was described to me as being a
cialis and so I thought it was a Cialis
and I,
I just took it.
So why is it guy like you need.
Seattle's have a huge got jail.
It's too big.
It's a good answer.
We don't have the resources to get it
normally a new yet,
you know,
I,
I'm your partner.
No,
it wasn't even necessarily party and
know I've taken like melon has,
but before,
and for people who haven't taken it,
you literally,
you know,
you go from being like that to just.
It puts the twist at the end of the
punch list at the end.
You know what I mean?
Is it like it?
It's,
it's a good time,
you know,
it's a good time to be a quote.
It's a good time.
Now.
What was this like?
One of them's gas station.
Rhino pills,
one of those things.
No,
I haven't.
Edit teammate basically tells me,
hey,
uh,
he was talking about how his girlfriends
are pharmacists and,
and he,
he's capable of getting all this stuff
and,
and all that type of stuff.
And I was like,
well I do,
I don't do drugs or anything like that.
And he's like,
you ever take a Cialis?
And I was like,
yeah.
He's like,
I got to Cialis.
And I was like,
well,
you said you don't do drugs or anything
like that,
but you would done drugs.
Well,
yeah.
Yeah.
But no,
he was talking about all these
painkillers and all this different shit
than other things on top that he has
because his girlfriend's a pharmacist
and he wasn't,
she getting this off brand stuff from
him.
It's like,
I don't know,
people get a lot of stuff from China.
I mean that's what happened with
Anderson.
Anderson got liquid cialis from China
and it was tainted.
Look,
this happens.
I know for a fact that everyone knows
for a fact that happens.
The supplement industry has a giant
issue with the people that mix the
stuff,
like if you have a VAT and you're mixing
up whatever,
creatine or something like that and
right before,
I mean,
if this is done in some country or some
place that doesn't have excellent
standards,
it's not scrupulous.
You could have been scooping up steroids
in the batch before that and you just
throw the creatine in it and some of it
gets contaminated and they don't clean
it.
Yeah.
That's pretty much a lock.
I'll get to that.
But okay.
So you take this off brand seattle guys
like
you ever do by Agros and all that stuff.
And I'm like,
yeah,
I've,
you know,
I've had melanie pain pills before and
he's like,
oh,
I got cialis.
And I'm like,
oh this is great.
So I ended up taking one of the cialis
bills and um,
um,
and I thought everything was fine and
dandy.
I had no clue.
Um,
what Ha,
you know,
that I was now having something else.
To me that was illegal.
I took a sales spiel on June the 14th of
June,
16th.
Um,
you cited,
came over to my house 6:00 in the
morning.
Hey,
what's up guys?
That coffee going offer when everybody
water bottles.
Super Nice,
hospitable.
Come in.
I'm laughing and joking with them.
I had no clue that that test was going
to be the test that derail my life.
And um,
you know,
right before UFC 200,
uh,
my manager mark,
he calls me over to his hotel room and
he said,
okay,
I want to talk to you man,
like,
what's going on?
He's like,
Hey,
you're not going to be fighting.
What are you talking about?
He's like,
you know,
you didn't feel you didn't pass your
drug test and a,
the level of hurt and just and
confusion.
And I literally had an anxiety attack
and I had never had one of those before.
What does that feel like?
I felt like the whole room just came in
on me,
like the whole room came down on me and
I was just,
I couldn't breathe.
I remember opening up his hotel window
looking for a balcony.
So I could just breathe and realize that
I'm like not trapped.
Um,
there's was literally the window opened
that much.
I was like,
what the fuck,
so you don't drop out my hotel in Vegas
where it was in Vegas,
fucking brick and I'm breathing.
They don't want gamblers leaping through
the banking.
I'm breathing through the thing,
calm myself down.
And um,
and I instantly started thinking about
the weight of the.
I had the weight of the world literally
on my back.
I knew that I knew that I wasn't going
to be fighting a few hours before
everyone else knew,
the public knew and I was just,
I could already start hearing
everything.
Even my own coaches,
we looking at me like just their hearts
were on the floor.
Like I had done so much to get back to
fighting at UFC 200.
Like getting my life in order,
getting the people around me in order to
get in my head,
my health,
my mind,
you know,
just being in order to beat DC.
And,
and like literally right now I've done
so much.
So much of the right things to be back
in a good position and right now you
know,
people look at me as if I still don't
have my shit together,
but the only thing that I did was I took
a pill that I thought was gonna get me a
boner and it literally,
it's caused me a lot of heartache and a
lot of disappointment and a lot of them
threw me back here in any way,
shape or form.
When someone gives you this pill and you
don't know where it came from,
you don't know.
What did you think,
man?
I don't know what's in this.
No,
I didn't.
I didn't think of it because I'm,
I had been dealing with the athletic
commission.
I've been in the UFC for a long time and
I've taken a little gas station Dick
Pills before,
like,
you know,
and I've never failed a drug test ever.
Did you?
Did you ever think that you might have
got lucky?
No,
I didn't think I got lucky.
I thought that you fail drug tests when
you're doing sketchy shit.
Right?
But didn't you think there might be some
sketchy shit and some Chinese?
No.
Station Rhino,
Dick Pill?
I,
um,
what you know about the rhinos.
My friend Ryan,
my friend Brian called it,
he was on the podcast.
He said,
you know,
John Likes to party.
I bet he took one of them Dick Pills.
No.
Um,
that's funny you called it.
Yeah.
Well he was,
he was on.
Oh,
I haven't.
I've taken them several times before.
And with the Nevada State Athletic
Commission,
I always pass my drug test and,
and I know that I would never do
anything to cheat this sport.
I've a lot of pride in my work ethic and
knowing that do dot,
I've been skinny my whole career.
Whooping people's ass.
I'm not a knockout artist.
I wouldn't because I'm smart and you
know,
I work hard.
Um,
but with you with the Nevada Athletic
Commission,
I never had an issue.
And then I was suspended when you
started came,
so I was never really educated on how
serious you shot a really was like,
I um,
I came back into the game and there's
like,
oh,
hey,
we got this new company name and Usada
instead of Nevada.
What were you suspended for when you to
cane?
Oh,
you
mean when they come into the sport?
I understand what you,
not when they come into your house.
So when you started came into the sport.
I was suspended because of my head.
Right.
And so I never had even met anyone who
worked for you side.
I'd never been sat down.
I know you sat a seminar what to do and
what not to do and how serious it is and
what could happen if you do this.
And all.
The thing I knew is I had to report
where I was at.
Like if I go to La for the weekend,
I got a little sad to know that I'm in
La because they test me at anytime.
That's the only thing I really knew
about Usada.
I didn't know that.
Doing something that I had done several
times before,
it could ultimately lose me a fight,
so I'm.
The only difference was I had taken like
little gas station pills and I've taken
by Agora before this was,
this teammate gave me something that was
Seattle is I thought the only thing that
it would do is make me bigger and
stronger for longer.
That's all I thought was going to be
happening and then when I find out that
that I just felt that drug test.
Do you know that via Viagra is actually
illegal in the Olympics?
I didn't know that.
You can't take that stuff.
The Viagra is a performance enhancer
though.
It's a vassal.
Dilate or I believe.
I believe that's how they describe it
and it actually has athletic performance
enhancing product properties to it.
How does it,
how does it help you?
I don't know.
You'd have to look into that,
but I think it's similar to in a lot of
ways to nitric oxide supplement,
like a,
like a pre workout and get your.
Yeah,
yeah.
It does something to open up your blood
cells and get you pumped.
I mean,
it does something not just to your Dick
but to all of your muscle.
Yeah.
I don't know if I would want it to be
pumped up during a fight.
I don't think it works that way.
I mean,
I don't think it actually can possibly
potentially help endurance.
Well,
yeah,
I know,
but I know that athletes take it for
that reason.
That's why it's banned from the
Olympics.
Yeah.
But,
um,
but yeah,
you know,
I understand that it wasn't your
intention.
It was not my intention.
I had no,
I had no clue that I needed to report
this to the side of because I thought,
you know,
literally I was report and everything
else.
What supplements,
what preworkout,
what,
you know,
my amino acids,
protein powder,
like you saw it,
had all my stuff.
And what happens once you find out?
Did you,
how'd you narrow it down to this pill?
I literally,
I went through my supplements and I,
um,
handed it to.
I hired a private lab in a lawyer and we
started handing it,
given them everything that I took,
which isn't really a lot of stuff at
all,
you know,
stuff that everyone should take fish
oil,
basic basic supplements,
protein,
protein powder,
fish oil,
you know,
liver cleanse that like,
or whatever.
Um,
just grapeseed extract that kind of
stuff,
very multivitamins for men.
Basic,
very basic stuff.
And,
um,
and then,
and then get nutrition is like,
you know,
we sweep,
scanned all of our stuff.
We know it's not from
that.
Got Nutrition website,
those fucking hilarious to the Gat
nutrition website at the moment.
We found out about that said John
sponsored
by Gat Nutrition.
So we've,
oh,
let's check that out.
Get nutrition to some fucking dude is
just,
they have a lot of great,
great products.
If you want to get bigger and stronger
than you can definitely go to them,
you know.
But as soon as we saw that,
we were like,
what in the holy fuck is he taking?
Oh No,
I mean,
but people saw you.
You got gigantic.
Huge.
That radically,
completely,
uh,
completely natural.
And that's what I have great pride in
being the natural athlete.
But,
um,
but,
uh,
so they got,
they got all the cat stuff,
test it and clear,
right.
Everything was clear.
Um,
this gets to have other things that you
don't regulate.
Absolutely.
But the things that they gave me,
they were super smart about and uh,
out in all the products I was clear and
um,
and uh,
so my managers,
I think outside of the box did you take
anything that could have possibly been?
And I was like,
I don't think so.
Then I was like,
well,
one of my teammates did give me this,
this dick pill.
And he's like,
I need those.
So we got those pills tested and sure
enough,
they,
uh,
in their ingredients,
they listed about five products in their
ingredients and they actually a,
there's actually seven products too that
weren't listed in the ingredients.
The two estrogen blockers were never in
their ingredients.
Um,
so,
um,
it was a tainted pill.
It was.
Say what I'm saying?
Yes.
So,
um,
so the you cited was able to tell,
okay,
this was totally inattention and there's
no way.
No way in Hell I'm John would take these
estrogen blockers on purpose.
First of all,
it was very small traces,
so it wasn't like I was loaded up with
estrogen blockers and um,
why the fuck would they put estrogen
blockers and a pill?
We believe that the factory that created
these,
uh,
these dick pills were maybe
manufacturing these pills in a dirty
laboratory,
whatever.
And they were just tainted.
Yes,
because each pill that we,
that we had tested,
some of them had more estrogen blockers,
some had almost no estrogen blockers,
some head small traces.
Actually none of the pills were
consistent.
So it was obvious that it.
And we,
we tested several different packages.
So it was obviously that,
that these pills were probably getting
made in the same machine and there was
just traces a little,
which is enough to show up in your
system when you get at some of these
dick pills that had none.
No estrogen blockers and be like,
damn,
why didn't I get that one?
Yeah,
exactly.
So I,
I took one that was just contaminated
enough and literally I got tested two
days later and it was in my system,
so it was,
it was obvious that it was complete
accident and even,
and even if I would have reported the
Deq pill to Usada,
they would have read the label and the
label would have never said that it was
estrogen blocker in there and I still
would have had a dirty.
Right.
That attainment contaminated.
Where does that leave you?
How much time did they suspend you for?
I got suspended for a year back from
starting from back in July.
So now I fight in July of two subs.
I love you.
I love what they're doing.
I don't agree with things like that.
Because what you took does not enhance
your performance?
No,
it doesn't.
Especially in such a trace amount.
I feel like in certain circumstances,
like there's been several fighters like
Chad Mendez,
he has a,
I believe he has eczema and he was
taking an Eczema cream that had some
sort of a.
was it a hormone precursor or a hormone?
Peptide,
I believe,
some sort of a hormone,
peptide.
I think that enhances the use of this
cream.
I don't.
I don't know the full.
I'm obviously not a doctor or a
scientist,
but there's something about suspending
someone for something like that.
That seems ridiculous.
Well,
in my situation they,
they
the,
the evening you said his lawyer,
he.
So he showed a little bit of remorse.
I could.
I could feel that he felt bad about what
was happening to me because I think he
could really,
even the arbitrators,
they could tell what had actually
happened,
but their problem was they said John was
just negligent.
Like you didn't.
You should have reported this pill,
but that doesn't.
It seems to me that's silly.
I mean that's even if I would have
reported the pill,
they would've read the ingredients and
they would've never saw that there was a
trace of,
of something that wasn't advertised.
So why?
Why suspend someone for something like
that?
Because they.
Because they have a zero tolerance
policy.
It was just like I was the first fighter
to ever take them to operation and and
they were more upset that I didn't let
them know that I took the pill.
Then what actually happened?
The rule,
as you tell us what you take and we can
point you in a different direction,
but I never told him what I took.
My whole argument.
Was it if I told you what I took,
it still was never on the label.
Yeah,
so unless you guys were going to spend
all the money to take it to a private
law or take it to a laboratory to test
this individually,
you get what I'm saying?
I still ran into the same situation.
I think it's great to protect people
from people that are cheating.
I don't think it's great to punish
someone for taking something that has a
trace amount of something that does the
absolutely no benefit whatsoever and
clearly it wasn't supposed to be in that
pill and wasn't supposed to be in that
pill and clearly wasn't being taken to
enhance athletic performance.
Right.
That seems silly.
It seems like a mess.
It seems like a mask that,
I mean,
I,
I understand their zero tolerance
policy.
I don't agree with it.
And this is more of the Chad Mendez
situation,
you know,
there's,
there's weird ones like Yoel Romero.
He tested positive for something.
They found out that it was a,
in one of the protein powders or
something.
He was taken.
It wasn't supposed to be in there,
wasn't listed that way and they gave him
an abbreviated sentence.
He should have.
No,
no,
no punishment whatsoever.
But I mean,
my whole thing,
Joe,
is I'm so grateful.
I'm still optimistic,
man.
I'm,
and I'm always looking for light in
every situation.
Um,
and I think that's the way I deal with
things.
I just,
I'm always trying.
I always believe there's going to be
good at the end of the day,
that's just how I am.
I'm just so grateful where most people
would be so upset with themselves and
all this type of stuff.
I'm really not.
I'm upset about the fans that are let
down who flew out to UFC 200 and things
like that.
But as far as the whole situation,
I'm just glad that that my,
my name will no longer be associated
with steroids,
but I'd rather be vulnerable or whatever
you want to call me,
you know,
whatever you want to call me.
But steroids that,
that was,
that would have really.
That was really bothering me.
So I'm just glad that it's out.
What actually happened?
Why did they choose to suspend you for
so long?
Just because of the negligence behind
it.
They didn't like the fact that I,
that I was handed a sex pill and I never
returned.
I never turned it into a them to check
it out.
And if they did,
they still would've kicked you off at
UFC too.
Yeah,
exactly.
So
I don't know.
That would have given you a more,
maybe a more abbreviated suspension,
but still it's,
it just seems ridiculous.
I wonder when we hand pills into Usada
or hand anything into these Saturday,
did they read the label and say,
Oh yeah,
you can take this or do they actually
take it somewhere and test it?
I'm sure they read the label.
I mean if they still would have been in
position,
yeah,
they are,
they're not going to test things.
I mean that's,
that's expensive.
And if it doesn't say it's on there,
there's no reason.
I mean if somebody gives you whey
protein powder,
well hey,
let's test this and make sure that it
doesn't have clomid in it or say
it would take weeks to get it back and
it cost thousands of dollars and if
you're doing that for every UFC fighter.
So yeah,
that's my whole thing.
I'm like,
even about,
I told you guys I took it,
you guys would have read the label and
it gave me the okay,
right.
Because we were allowed to have what's
an vagrancy?
Alice and us,
we're actually allowed to but because
mine's was tainted and I didn't ask,
they were just like,
well you never asked so we're going to
suspend you.
So I don't really know why they decided
to go ahead with the full maximum
punishment.
But I tend not to question things that
I'm.
So I'm really young and,
and you know,
I believe that my best years of my prime
is even still ahead of me,
so I'm not even tripping about it.
I'm like,
you know,
whatever,
like,
you know,
I believe in God,
so I try to always point things back
towards God.
I'm just saying,
well,
you know,
maybe this is God's plan for me.
Maybe I need this time away from the
sport just to continue working on my own
personal development and growth as a man
and,
and I,
I do believe I'm in a good place right
now.
So I'm excited to see where I will be
back in July when it's time for me to
actually compete with Glen.
In July you released?
Uh,
I think around July
when was used 200 July,
eighth July fifth GFC,
200 was December 10th or 11th?
December 11th.
I'm sorry,
that was a ufc 205 UFC 200 was July
ninth.
Okay.
So July seventh I'll be eligible to
fight two days before UFC 200 July.
Seventh,
2017.
I'll be able to compete and I'd like to
fight right in July.
Yeah,
there's a big UFC July fourth car that
we put on every year,
but you're going to miss that.
MMM.
What do you think now when you look at
the UFC title?
Picture cormier just had to pull out.
He injured himself and a rumble.
Johnson decided not to fight Luke saucy.
He decided to step back and wait for
cormier.
You know,
I don't believe.
I think that's a smart idea.
Um,
Musashi is capable.
He's a very smart fighter of being
rumble.
Johnson and I'm.
It's a high risk,
low,
low return,
low return.
Why?
Why do you need to be Sassy?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The title fight picture is sort of
waiting.
A lot of it is waiting on you.
That's a big part of it.
Waiting on you to return.
Yeah.
I'm excited to go back and get my baby.
I have they had conversations with you
about when you do return,
what kind of fight you would have.
Would you go right to a title fight?
Fight a contender?
No,
it is.
No one's spoken to me about whether I
get an immediate shot or a,
whether they make me a fight at least
once or twice before or no,
I have no clue what they're actually
planning on doing.
But
how often do you communicate with UFC?
I,
I literally haven't spoken to Dana
White,
uh,
since uh,
like a week before ufc 200
now that the UFC has been sold.
Well actually not a week before a fight
week of UFC 200 years anyways.
Now the UC has been sold and there's
these new owners.
What's your thoughts on all this?
I'm excited to,
uh,
to get to know the new owners of the
UCL.
I don't,
I've had a few interactions with ra
before.
Um,
but um,
obviously I've never dealt with them on
a business level,
but I'm excited.
I do Miss Lorenzo Fertitta.
I think I had a great relationship with
him.
He was always the calm,
cool,
collected one,
the one that I could actually,
you know,
like leave emotion behind it and like
really have a good conversation with.
So,
you know,
we had a great relationship in that way.
Um,
but I'm,
I'm,
I'm excited about the new leadership.
Yeah,
it's interesting,
right?
It's a new chapter in it is a lot of who
knows that that's what gets exciting and
they're,
they're obviously very entertainment
business savvy and see where it,
where it leads to.
When you look at the state of mixed
martial arts today,
what problems do you see in mma?
Hmm.
Do you see anything that stands out
glaringly?
Like,
here's,
here's some things that I think about
weight cutting weight,
cuttings of giant issue.
When you see all this work that's being
put in by Usada to make sure that people
aren't taking things to the point where
someone like you who's taking something
that's not a performance enhancer,
get suspended for a year.
And the idea is that you're supposed to
be protecting fighters from someone
who's doing something that's dangerous,
right?
That's the tape behind it.
The cheating and somehow could cause
potential danger or damage to people.
But what about cutting man,
isn't it?
I mean,
it isn't extreme weight cutting.
One of the most dangerous things.
Um,
so we're going to put this on pause.
I have to pee.
Oh,
okay,
go ahead.
Go ahead.
I was drinking this water and coffee.
Good.
Talk about weight cutting.
John's going to be right back.
Go right to that door.
Take the eggs on light and don't let
your publicist talk you to coming back
in here.
She's probably listening.
Interesting.
Very forthcoming with the boner pill
talk.
I think that's important.
I mean if anyone's going to believe him,
that's the only way to really get it out
there.
I fucking hate weight cutting.
I do.
I had a conversation with Ari Emanuel
about it and I'm going to have a
conversation soon with Novitsky about it
and I just think is the most.
It's the most unnecessary and dangerous
aspect and fighting the most important
aspect in fighting his fighters,
being healthy and in shape and competing
to the best of our abilities and if
there's anything that inhibits that
other than not training,
it's the dehydration effect of Wake
County.
I think weight cutting is.
It's terrible and now that they can't
use ivs,
I'm obviously again,
hate to say this again.
I'm not a doctor so I don't know what.
What is the most effective method of
rehydrating?
But I've talked to doctors and I guess
they vary in their opinions because some
people say it's orally is the best way
through drinking water slowly,
but some people say it's not.
Some doctors say no.
Ivy is a far superior method,
especially when it comes to rehydrating
the brain,
which could take as much as 72 hours.
Um,
I think it's interesting that in boxing
most of the deaths have come from the
lighter weight divisions and they
attribute that also to weight cutting
and did
duration.
Okay.
So you have a bag that I'm talking way
too much.
Ah,
I knew it.
She's like you said too much about the
Dick Pills,
mom on the dick pills longer,
faster,
harder Jones.
Really?
How much we
do you cut?
Um,
I don't really cut a lot of weight at
all.
I,
um,
I get myself down to about
2:20 on fight week.
And then what do you weigh right now?
Write down to 30 2:30 to 2:30.
But I get myself down to about 2:20
during fight week.
And then I make sure that the day of
winds I cut about five pounds of water.
That's nothing.
No,
it was nothing.
But that's a testament to just,
you know,
I've been doing it for so long now I
know my job is to be,
you know,
to have my weight together.
When you see conor mcgregor weigh in at
1:45 and it looks like,
like death,
right?
You know that when I see those,
that that's what scares the shit out of
me when I see people that are just
clearly cutting way too much weight or
when I ever saw was travis Luder when he
fought Anderson Silva,
Travis Luder,
he like his lips were dried up and
cracked and he was shuffling to the
scale.
Like he couldn't walk.
He didn't have the strength to pick his
feet up and walk.
He was like,
just shuffling towards the end.
He still didn't make the way.
It's shitty but scares me the most
because a,
there's not a lot of options when it
comes to weight classes.
If someone's one 85 and they go,
you know,
man,
I'm having a hard time fighting one 85.
Then they look at you and they're like,
fuck that.
This is two.
Oh five.
That's a 20 pound jump.
Twenty pounds is a big jump.
It's huge.
Yeah.
As far as will it come for me,
I just,
you know,
it's never really been an issue for me.
I've always made way.
I've never come close to missing way.
Um,
I just think,
aren't you
lucky though that you are in the
neighborhood of two?
Oh five.
Like what have you.
We're just a little bigger and you know,
you're in the heavyweight.
If I was a little bigger than I will
let,
I would go to heavyweight.
Um,
but you know,
a part of,
of our,
of our job is to keep our weight under
control.
You know,
if you know,
you're gonna be fine at two.
Oh five.
You have no business walking around it,
you know,
a to 50.
You know what I mean?
So,
you know,
he's just,
there's enough weight classes.
No,
I,
I would like there to be at least
another weight class when it comes to
us.
Big Boys,
you know what I mean?
I would love it if they went to 25 to
25.
Yeah,
I believe that there was a to 25 pound
weight class,
I'd be,
I'd be a two belt holder myself.
You feel like that would be a better
weight class for you?
Uh,
I,
I love to a five.
I make 25 just fine,
but to 25 I compete against 2:25 pounder
any day,
you know,
face the guy who's shown up fight night
at 2:40 or whatever and you know,
as bargains heavyweights pretty much
every,
you know,
I've been doing it my whole career
anyway.
So,
um,
it'd be great to see,
uh,
some,
something that bridges that gap a little
bit from 12.
Five to two 65.
Yeah,
I would like to see it.
I would like to see between 55 and 70
slash 70 and 85.
Just 15 pounds a giant leap.
Twenty pounds from 85 to 205.
And then of course two.
Oh,
five to heavyweight,
that's a huge leap.
That's 65 years
pound check antic yeah.
A lot of people are like,
why don't you go up to heavyweight and
try to win the belt there.
I'm just like,
you realize what you're asking me to do.
These,
these guys are very skilled.
He's got a very skilled and,
and they,
they can waive it for 60 pounds more
than me.
That's very dangerous.
But,
but have you thought about doing heavy
weight?
I do want to challenge,
uh,
for the heavyweight title.
Um,
but I'm waiting for the perfect
opponent.
And when you do do that,
when you challenge for the heavyweight
title,
are you going to gain weight?
Are you going to fight it the way you
were at?
I'll fight right around two,
2:30.
So you will not lose any weight at all.
I would try to eat a lot and make sure
my endurance and speed and agility is
where it needs to be.
And uh,
I've beaten up a lot of heavyweights.
Man,
you know,
the only people who are at Jackson's
have seen that.
I've submitted a lot of heavyweights.
I've slammed a lot of heavyweights of
manhandled a lot of heavyweights,
but um,
but,
um,
and I've done it right at the weight I
am now,
so I know that,
that I,
that I'm capable,
I just wanted to make sure that I
compete against the,
the right stylistic matchup for me when
I do go to heavyweight and challenge for
that title.
One of the things you said earlier that
I thought was really intense.
Nice.
You said you're not going to spar hard
again.
Yeah.
No,
not until it was time.
I feel like I've been majorly preserving
myself,
so I'm leading up to the oven st proof.
I,
I took almost as if no concussions
whatsoever.
And then I've been a suspended now for
another year and I've taken no
concussions.
So,
um,
while I feel like a lot of these guys
are in this race to,
to get better,
I'm getting a lot better.
I'm getting a lot stronger.
My wrestling and Jujitsu was getting a
lot sharper.
Um,
but I've,
I've completely,
my brain is feeling great right now.
I haven't been polluting it with shit
and I haven't damaged it.
And so I just feel like,
uh,
you got the best fighter in light
heavyweight history,
who's still the youngest guy in the
division who hasn't taken any damage
whatsoever and it's completely
regenerating himself and I'm going to
come back and have this explosive,
explosive second half of my career.
No,
there's a lot of guys that are doing
that now where they're not sparring
hard.
Um,
cowboy barely spars at all.
I don't think even spars.
He does some tactical sparring where,
you know,
just tap touch,
just move around.
But he's mostly just doing drills.
That's what I'm going to get into.
He said he changed that after the Dos
Anjos fight.
He said when he lost a hot failed Dos
Anjos,
he just felt like maybe he had
diminished himself too much with hard
sparring.
Do a lot of these guys.
They,
they leave their career in the gym,
you know,
like you get no points.
I got,
there's a few guys that come to mind
right now.
I Jackson's who,
who get punched in the head.
I'm sitting there watching them and I
watch a lot of fighting and I'm still a
huge student of the game,
um,
but I'm not doing it myself.
These guys laugh and like,
you know,
they'll get punched in,
they start giggling or are they just.
And that's the dumbest shit to me.
Every like getting punched in the head
pisses me off if I leave practice with a
headache,
I'm pissed,
you know,
I feel like,
uh,
I just took away from myself or just
there was one more punch I could have
saved for an actual event.
And so right now,
um,
you know,
I have a great chin.
I've never been wrapped or wobble.
Um,
and uh,
I want to keep it that way.
I'm going to preserve my myself,
um,
because the skills will come.
Um,
but you know,
that brain wants,
wants,
is a yellow,
is yellow forever
Jello forever.
And that's a security thing when you see
guys go,
when you see a guy like maybe chuck
Liddell was one of the best examples
ever because he had an iron jaw at one
point in time.
He was just indestructable.
And then he saw,
he just get wobbled by shots that
normally he would just eat like,
like a tic TAC.
Yeah.
And when it goes,
it just goes and it does not come back.
I'm saving my shit.
Joe,
I hear you saying I want you to now
Jackson's is such a crazy place because
it's a hotbed of mma talent and it's a,
it's a magnet for talented people to
come there to get better because they
know they're gonna be training with a
bunch of animals there.
But I'm hearing now with the opening of
the new place that you just,
you guys just got so many tough dudes
come in.
They're trying to make a name.
Right?
Do you have an issue with that when it
comes to sparring where guys want to try
to make a names barring,
you know,
I personally don't have an issue with
it.
So me,
uh,
since we've had our new gym,
um,
it's this gigantic facility and we need
people to pay the bills.
So we literally,
we allow a lot of people to come into
the gym who I don't think are always
qualified to be in the gym,
um,
but we allow everybody to come.
And so anybody off the street,
like any normal person?
No you can't.
No.
So our gym manager,
he does have an extensive,
like a tryout thing that he does where
he puts you through his jujitsu
wrestling and kicking and striking and
make sure you are knowledgeable about
the game.
So you have to have experience,
like how much experience do they have to
have?
They have to be like an amateur MMA
fighter.
There's a lot of damage belt in Jujitsu.
Like you just,
you can't,
you can't be a guy off the street who
don't know.
She has no shit.
But outside of that,
you know,
if you have a general idea of martial
arts and you know,
that we were opening the door to a lot
of people right now.
So
pro fight jam or do they offer classes
for beginners
amateur classes?
Um,
so have,
you know,
almost nothing.
You're in the amateur classes.
And then there's the pro pro pro
practices where you literally get,
you know,
guys who aren't very knowledgeable
training next to me and Holly Holm,
cowboy cerrone,
and you know,
so it's,
it's,
it's a fan experience for sure.
And it's an experience of a lifetime for
a lot of people.
And I'm happy for a lot of these guys
who come in here inspiring my shield.
I was against the train with me and the
rest of us,
uh,
because I can only imagine wanting to,
you know,
you get to play ball with Lebron James
and you just got out of college or you
never went to college.
Like I am happy for them as long as they
don't get in my way.
Did.
That is the big difference though,
is someone who wants to come and play
with Lebron James,
you know,
you want to make a name for yourself.
So with me,
you could dunk on Lebron James and were
like,
oh,
I can't believe you did that.
But.
So the difference between that and
fighting
I have,
I have a way of,
of not letting this affect my game
personally.
Um,
I'm a,
I'm a decent judge,
like I can read people's character a
little bit and uh,
have,
have I see you for the first time.
You are obviously about to 62.
Oh,
five whatever to 20 and you,
it's all about the way you look at me.
So if you come into the gym and you even
look like you have an ounce of a chip on
your shoulder or like an ounce of Holy
Shit,
that's John Jones.
I'm getting ready to,
to spar him today.
Like alright,
like anything weird that's going on with
your eye contact with me then I'm just
not gonna mess with you.
Say Hi to you and welcome to Jackson's
and say,
hey man,
do you want a spar?
I'm like,
Hey,
I don't know.
I just,
I don't have any room for,
for people trying to prove anything with
me.
There's a lot of that there.
Isn't there?
Yeah,
it happens.
So me,
the best way you can work with me when
you come to Jackson and just come up and
introduce yourself,
be kind,
be polite,
be respectful and um,
show me that you are here to get better
and uh,
and that you are not here to,
you know,
even some guys that come in and ask for
a picture of their first day here and
I'm just like,
it's like do earn,
like why don't you come here,
work your ass off for a few days,
few weeks or whatever,
and then get to this place where you
feel like you're comfortable to expert
picture instead of just being here and
being a fan.
People want those fucking pictures is
instantaneously.
Yes.
Like Bro,
you're here,
you're in the church right now.
You're in the met.
Like you don't take a picture here.
Like,
you know.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I just know what you mean.
No,
like,
yeah,
you should.
That's not where your mind should be at
facebook page.
Right?
Yo,
look,
wide trailer today is just like I told
you I was bad motherfucker.
Yeah.
Or Yeah,
you'll see that they'll tag you in a
pitcher and his thing had just trained
with the boat and really we didn't even
train together.
We like you were just in the room.
But um,
but I do see the benefits of habits.
So many new people coming in.
I mean everyone has something to teach
and you can learn from,
from anybody from any country if you
will,
if you have an open mind enough.
And a lot of the guys come in with a
great attitude and they're just really
grateful to be there and there.
And they,
um,
they go with a lot of the top dogs and
you know,
we can kind of beat him up a little bit,
because they're the new guy or whatever.
Um,
but every once in a while you get that
one guy was something improving it.
And I've really found,
came up with a great way to protect
myself from those types of people.
But you've run into those.
Um,
most people,
like I'm always very defensive when I'm
going with the guy who I felt like he
could be trying to prove something,
like even when we're drilling,
my defense is always on.
I don't,
I don't give someone the opportunity to
take a swing or ticket punch.
I've had one guy hit me with a monster
is overhand,
right while we're drilling.
And that was intentionally to,
to knock me out.
And uh,
instead of retaliating,
I just,
I said,
uh,
man,
you okay?
And he's like,
uh,
yeah,
I'm around.
I'm sorry,
I just,
I don't know what happened.
And I was just like,
okay,
well that was,
that was fun,
man,
that's working with you,
will never ever work with you again.
At one guy punched me in the balls
intentionally to not too long ago.
And uh,
and that was his last time ever trained
with me as well.
So it's
smart to stay away from you,
but you do find those disturbed people
that get involved in fighting and um,
they do want to take a chance at a guy
like Jon Jones take a swing at you.
Man,
we'll connect and knocked him out,
knocked out Jon Jones.
I go like a few times that it has
happened to,
uh,
I'll,
I'll let my teammates,
now I'm going to match what you're
trying to do to me.
So,
you know,
don't be surprised if I fuck you up with
something that's a little bit more than
what you would do to a trading partner
if,
if I realize you're trying to hurt me.
Do you meditate,
John?
I used to meditate a lot.
Now I'm more big into visualization.
When did you use to meditate?
I'm right around 2000,
around 2010,
2011.
Um,
I went through this huge spiritual thing
where I,
um,
I became obsessed with,
the power of the mind and um,
I got into a deep,
like really deep just um,
meditation and visualization and just
realizing how powerful our minds
actually are.
Like how we really do paint our world
with our thoughts and our level of self
belief.
And so,
um,
right around 2010,
I just took myself to this different
mental level where I took myself on
being an average joe kind of.
You'd probably hate every show.
Uh Huh.
That's aggressive.
It wasn't used to that name.
Such a goofy name.
It's good.
It's like a blank.
It's like cardboard.
There's nothing to it.
Yeah.
So I took myself on being very average
minded to actually believing that I was
the shit and believing that I could be
the shit and that I could be the goat
and be the greatest and never lose into
like I take myself to a different place
mentally.
And it,
a lot of it came from,
um,
mental practice and meditation and
visualization and just seeking knowledge
from people who are strong believers
because like I'm Les Brown and Tony
Robbins and guys like that.
I just became really obsessed with just
learn about the power of the mind.
So I used to meditate.
Now I just kind of,
I have a lot of things that have stuck
with me,
a lot of ways of believing that stuck
with me that just subconsciously I know
who I am and what I'm capable of and how
I believe apart from my mind actually is
I'm a firm believer in meditation
because I believe that human beings can
get caught up,
especially someone involved in a very
difficult endeavor like you are.
You can get caught up in the momentum of
your life and sometimes it's very hard
to reset.
It's a very hard to separate yourself
from it and get a balanced and as much
as you can objective perspective,
and I think one of the best ways to do
that is to take time.
We sit and you close your eyes and you
do nothing and just concentrate on your
breathing and just just set it all aside
and extract yourself.
Extract your consciousness from the
momentum of your life and I think a lot
of people don't do that and they get
caught up in this hurricane of existence
where everything is just constantly
going on.
Your phone won't stop ringing.
There's fucking people knocking at your
door.
You got this going on that going on and
you got to go catch this flight.
No Shit,
you got fight coming up and Oh shit,
you got this and that.
And sometimes you lose yourself.
You lose yourself in that wave of life.
I definitely lost myself at one point in
my life.
Um,
and I feel like right now I'm at this
position where I am,
I am myself and I can see John Bones
Jones and I'm like,
I can like look at my career from a fan
perspective.
You get what I'm saying?
And um,
and actually make fun of myself like,
Damn you fucking idiot.
Like what have you done?
Like,
you know what I mean?
um,
I,
I have,
I have a good way of detaching something
inside of me and,
and,
and seeing what's happening and okay,
oh no,
it's not over.
You've got to do is just do this,
do that,
do that.
And you get what I'm saying.
I'm so,
I'm not,
I don't,
I'm not necessarily meditating these
days,
but I do have the capability of taking
away who I actually am at this point and
realizing that this is just a part of me
or this is just a situation in my life.
This is my actual life.
This isn't my,
this isn't my final destination,
this is just a small moment in time that
I'm going through right now.
You get what I'm saying?
I get what you're saying.
So,
um,
so that,
that's my form of meditation.
I step away from terrible situations and
look and look at myself as if it's the
future and I'm looking back on what's
happened to me or what's happening and I
say,
okay,
how can I get myself out of this?
How can I make this better?
What do I need to do to turn this
around?
What do I,
you get what I'm saying.
Being completely emerged in the moment
and thinking that,
oh,
I can't get out.
Like,
you know,
so
not said earlier.
The UFC two.
Oh,
five was in December.
No,
November locked up due to a five.
Oh,
two.
five,
500,
sorry.
What I'm thinking of in December,
when is your grappling match with Dan
Henderson?
December 11th.
The stats.
Okay.
That's what I'm fucked up on.
Um,
what is this is this is this Ebi rules?
So this is submissions,
chills,
Sonnen's.
I think that the president of it or
something like that.
Yeah.
Then we have the,
you have the information for all that.
Let's put it up to tell people how they
could see that.
What,
what made you decide to do this?
Just to mix it up while you're off.
Yeah,
I uh,
uh,
they reached out to me.
I did like a small,
a grappling event.
Like I was at an autograph signing.
I saw that.
Yeah,
some guy was like,
hey,
you ever roll?
And like competitively.
And I was like,
no,
actually I haven't since 2009 or
something.
Like I did one Jujitsu match my whole
career and I want it but for some issues
against these,
these guys or whatever.
He's like,
man,
you should come over and roll with me.
And I'm like,
what build are you?
And he's like,
I think he,
the guy who challenged me was like a
purple belt or something.
And I'm like,
uh,
you know,
I really don't do that type of stuff.
I,
you know,
I would have to go home,
I don't have any clothes or anything.
And he's like,
oh,
we were selling gs over here in rash
guards.
And I'm like,
I was like,
I don't think I'm going to real man.
Like I,
you know.
And so he's like a,
well at least come over and say hi.
There's a lot of kids over there.
A lot of people who would just love to
see you come.
So some support to the Jujitsu
community.
I'm like,
all right,
I could do that.
And so when I went over there after my
autograph signing,
there was a bunch of people standing
around and I was greeting everybody and
the guy was like,
hey,
like are you going to roll with me or
what?
And I was just like,
in a lot of people heard them and I was
just like,
I feel like when someone's trying to a,
I feel like someone wins when they call
you out and you don't oblige them.
Right.
You know what I mean?
So I was just like.
And this guy's head is,
it's a small victory knowing that I
backed down and it's,
we're not punching,
it's,
it's Jujitsu,
right?
So no one's going to get hurt.
It's just like,
you know what,
let me live a little and just do this,
you know,
I'm sure the kids are gonna,
love it and people are going to.
So I,
uh,
I was like,
all right,
give me a rash guard.
So they gave me a rash guard and I
literally,
I didn't even warm up.
I just got to do one of these.
And then I ended up tapping these two
guys out fairly quick.
And um,
I think some of these people are from
submission underground.
They saw those videos and they're,
they're starting this new promotion,
um,
where they're actually paying fighters
pretty with that.
Like they're taking care of the
athletes.
You know,
really?
Yeah.
Do People Watch it on paper view?
Is that what it is?
So I think you can watch it online.
You could stream it online for a price.
Okay.
And um,
so here it is a,
okay,
it's flow grappling.com.
F L O grappling.com,
Sunday,
December 11th at 2:30.
And I think this is Ebi rules.
If this is the shale sunnen thing,
so to see if that,
if you could see that in there,
Jamie,
scroll up and see what the rules are.
I,
I still don't even know what the rules
are.
I think it's the mission only.
Yeah,
submission only,
but I think Ebi rules is a Ebi rules is
a very interesting to get me.
But Ebi is Eddie Bravo,
invitational rules.
What he did is he figured out a way to
avoid draws and what he does is he has
guys,
they fight for a or they grapple for a
determined time period.
Then at the end of the time period
minutes I heard,
yeah,
they exchange a bad positions.
Like one guy will start off.
Well you start off what's called spider.
So spiderweb aside,
control with,
not the arm bar locked up,
but the arm hooked,
you know the arm hooked so your you have
your legs across the arms,
trapped and ready go.
So the guy on the bottom is trying to
escape.
You're trying to hold him down or you
can start off with the over under from
back control so you don't have a choke
locked in,
but you have over under.
You have both hooks in and you're on the
back and they say ready,
go.
So it's how fast the person could escape
versus how fast you could submit them.
At the end of the exchange back of what?
Say if you submit your guy and then he
has an opportunity to try to submit you.
If you submit him faster than he
submitted you,
you went.
If you submit him and he doesn't submit
you,
you went with your escape.
Both escape and he'd do it again.
And then if you both escape again,
you do it one more time and then they
calculate all the time it took for each
one to escape.
And the person who has the least amount
of time and escape the quickest winds up
winning.
I'm winning this shit.
Dan Henderson quite a bit smaller than
you two.
Yeah,
I would imagine.
Yeah.
I wonder how much you weigh right now.
[inaudible] 85.
And I don't think he's cutting a whole
lot of weight.
It's not a big guy,
you know.
And um,
it's interesting like him fighting
Michael Bisping,
I think that's probably going to be his
last fight.
A lot of people thought he should have
won that fight.
Super close fight.
He retired and he argued in.
Yeah,
I think he did.
I think he decided that's it.
Yeah.
So I'm sure this means a lot to them to
be able to be able to beat me even in a
grappling match.
That's quite the way to end your career.
Yeah.
So I don't know how hard he's training,
but I've,
I'm putting a little effort into it for
sure.
Yeah.
Will you tell me before you just getting
really in love with Gigi?
I do.
I do love Jujitsu.
Yeah.
My,
my,
my professor has a,
he's a great coach,
man.
They call them to say,
I think it's Portuguese for like buck
tooth or something like that,
but his real name,
Roberto all car.
He's several times world champion
Jujitsu.
I think it'd be funny magazines quite a
few times and he's won all these.
That's huge.
All these world champion,
I think he's a five time world champion.
Wow.
Um,
and he,
he literally is right there with me
every practice and you know,
he knows that have,
I've never done training,
but he,
um,
he uh,
he doesn't settle like I'm technically a
white belt,
but he's,
he,
every position,
he's like,
you know,
you got to do this right?
You got to do,
put your hand here.
They'll make this type of protecting the
super technical and that's great.
I feel like I'm getting pretty good
right now.
That's awesome man.
If you just dedicate yourself to that
before you know,
you come back,
you'll,
you should got like,
you,
you have a big jump.
Yeah.
People are going to hate me,
bro.
I'm going to.
My is going to be like,
oh my.
I'm just going to take people out for
her care to ride your ass out,
submit you like don't expect any more
standup striking for me.
Really.
I'm joking.
I'll tell them,
who knows what you're going to do right
now.
I don't know.
I'm going to do at this point,
but I'm getting better and I'm
preserving myself.
Elizabeth,
it's good to see you.
Smile.
See laughs.
Good.
See,
happy.
It's good to see you optimistic about
your future and I think you've got a
great perspective right now and I really
hope you keep it together man.
Oh,
I'm a big fan as a person,
as a fighter.
I'm glad we did this.
I am too.
All right.
All right brother folks.
We're done for today.
See Ya.
Bye.
John Jones.
That was fun.